bienvenue bonjour à tous aujourd'hui
nous allons avoir trois intervenants qui
vont parler de la décarbonation de notre
système il peut vendre nos entreprises
vont pouvoir s'adapter et agir en ce
sens nous avons donc trois intervenants
ce soir le premier intervenant et d'une
aile bertrand qui le président cjd
poitiers châtellerault qui nous parlera
de pourquoi ce webinaire ce soir je suis
un petit historique et donc contre un
petit peu la création ensuite nous
allons prendre un petit peu de hauteur
puisque nous allons nous adresser à
pierre minaudier qui est le président du
cjd france pierre va nous parler de tout
ce qu'il est possible de faire
actuellement en france pour essayer
d'appuyer sur les différents dispositifs
qui sont mis en place pour le
gouvernement et donc la question c'est
finalement qu'est ce que peut faire le
cjd qu'est ce que fait le cjd et puis on
va prendre encore un peu plus de hauteur
là on va s'approcher des étoiles on va
tutoyer les étoiles on va se rapprocher
de jean marc jancovici jean marc
jancovici est un expert qui est associée
la carbone 4 qui a un cabinet conseil
spécialisé dans la transmission de la
transition énergétique et l'adaptation
aux changements climatiques
il est aussi président d'un think tank
s'appelle the chief project il est aussi
professeur à l'école des mines paris
tech dont vous allez pouvoir aussi
découvrir tous les contenus qui sont
disponibles sur youtube
c'est très enrichissant il ya énormément
d'informations
tout ça pour dire que ce dont on va
parler jean marc jancovici c'est pas
tiré de 3 8 et 4 postes facebook c'est
vraiment du solide et c'est des
fondations sur des données scientifiques
vraiment très précises
voilà cette présentation des différents
intervenants de ce soir je vais passer
maintenant la parole à lionel bertrand
le président cjd poitiers châtellerault
merci vincent
c'est un grand honneur et cela a
beaucoup de sens de vous retrouver pour
ce webinaire monsieur jancovici un grand
honneur parce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
un expert de premier rang sur le thème
de la transition et énergétiques et que
vous êtes pour cela très sollicité cela
a beaucoup de sens car nous sommes
convaincus
ici au cjb de la nécessité d'agir de
changer notamment dans le monde de
l'entreprise
plus que jamais et urgemment
initialement nous devions nous retrouver
aujourd'hui au palais des congrès du
futuroscope pour un évènement organisé
avec le soutien des gammes une
interassociations local des métiers de
l'entreprise
notre événement devait réunir plus de
2000 personnes des étudiants des chefs
d'entreprise et des citoyens en les
invitant à s'engager à faire partie des
précurseurs à faire leur part à cette
journée d'action a été reprogrammée au 6
mai 2021 pour les raisons que nous
pouvons tous deviné faire sa part comme
le colibri pour éteindre un incendie de
forêt sauf que dans le monde de
l'entreprise on n'est pas des colibris
mais plutôt des éléphants je veux dire
par là que notre impact et nos moyens
d'action de dirigeants sont bien plus
importants que ceux du citoyen nous
sommes bien sûr très heureux que ce
projet ait pu émerger notre section
mais il ya autre chose d'important que
j'aimerais partager avec vous tous ce
soir
la pensée est devenu projet le temps
d'une discussion avec un autre gillet on
en a parlé dans la section et ses 25% de
nos membres qui se sont engagés
spontanément pour travailler sur le
projet pendant un an on en a parlé
autour de nous et c'est à yann le cjd
nationale les partenaires publics les
collectivités locales les entreprises
privées mais vous aussi monsieur jean
comme ici audrey pulvar frédérique bedos
qui ont répondu oui
pour nous soutenir et cela fait chaud au
coeur ça donne espoir oui on a des
obstacles façade il nous semble
insurmontable
ce que l'on ignore trop souvent ce sont
toutes les personnes ressources autour
de nous qui serons nous porte et nous
soutenir a réalisé l'impossible parce
que la cause est juste parce qu'elle a
du sens ce pack à ce qu'elle représente
un progrès dans le monde a besoin cela
on l'a ressenti très fortement
je suis convaincu que tout chef
d'entreprise qui se lancera dans cette
transition il trouvera des fruits et des
ressources insoupçonnées
aujourd'hui nous sommes très fortement
chahutés par cette crise ducobu 19
beaucoup d'entre nous en ressorte sonné
il peut être naturel de revenir de
chercher à revenir à la situation
d'avant et nous savons tous que c'est
vers un monde d'après qu'il convient de
nous diriger pour aller vers ce monde de
demain nous avons besoin de rêveurs tout
autant que de personnes entrer dans la
réalité
monsieur gens peuvent ici vous êtes de
ceux qui ont les pieds sur terre
votre apport est essentiel ce que
j'apprécie chez vous c'est bien entendu
votre qualité d'expert mais aussi votre
courage qui se manifeste par la défense
de position peu consensuel notamment
concernant le nucléaire
votre pragmatisme vous ne vous arrêtez
pas au constat vous proposez et continué
à chercher des solutions
votre engagement votre intervention à
nos côtés en est un exemple
votre générosité puisque vous avez
accepté à titre gracieux d'intervenir ce
soir votre humour aussi jeudi pince sans
rire ça vous va que notre action est
aligné sur nos valeurs on n'a plus grand
chose à craindre
merci d'être cet exemple inspirant merci
au cjd de permettre des rencontres et
des temps de change comme ce soir je
cède la parole à pierre notre président
national qui nous fait aussi l'honneur
de sa présence
bonjour
à tous et à toutes merci beaucoup
lionel et ben sont pour pour cette
invitation et à jour marque aussi d'être
présent ce soir je pense à un événement
très important pour nous tous
entrepreneurs mais aussi pour la planète
et ses parts cc oui binaire c'est cette
discussion et ses engagements qu on peut
peut-être à notre échelle commencé à
révolutionner un peu le monde puisque
comme d'autres créateurs je remercie le
disait créateur du sgen et on est tous
un peu révolutionnaire
je pense qu'on aura bien besoin d'une
bonne révolution en tout cas à l'aube on
sent qu'on sent pointer ici ce que je
voulais vous partagez c'était avant tout
comme comme le nail le disait deux
sujets le premier sujet c'est je pense
qu'il est temps de poser les temps
d'oser d'être être des dirigeants
autrement différents et c'est ce qu'on a
toujours été c'est notre marque de
fabrique au cjd cette liberté cette
fraîcheur cette audace qu'on a je pense
que l est très important dans ces
moments là il faut savoir va falloir
savoir prendre des positions fortes et
je pense que les idées savent le faire
et les entrepreneurs qui ne sont pas
j'ai dit mme qui se reconnaissent la
danse seront le faire aussi et j'ai
confiance moi j'ai vraiment confiance
dans cet avenir qui arrivent mais si j
-dc assez bien plus qu'un mouvement
d'entrepreneurs engagé et humaniste
c'est aussi un alors le chi project est
un film tant que moi je définirais le
cjd comme un action un conte et des dés
makers ont fait on fait les choses au
cjd en fait on fait par
l'expérimentation fait par la force du
collectif
on n'a pas peur de défricher des idées
qui peuvent être à contre-courant et on
l'a fait dans toute notre histoire et je
pense qu'on continuera à le faire
en menant des expérimentations qui
peuvent paraître un peu folle on a une
expérimentation en cours en ce moment
qui s'appelle les vingt virtuoses 20
entreprises qui sont embarqués dans un
voyage presque initiatique de quelle
pourrait être finalement des entreprises
qui contribuent au bien commun et je
pense que la notion bien commun est en
train de
d'émerger en ce moment et c'est très
important pour l'ensemble de la société
va falloir développer de nouvelles
approches comme lionel l'a dit et
questionner une manière d'agir en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que notre
raison d'être au cjd qui est de bâtir
des entreprises responsables durable et
agréable n'a jamais été autant
d'actualité à mon sens le cjd c'est pour
ceux ceux des auditeurs qui sont là et
qui ne connaissent peut-être pas si j'y
vais parce qu'ils ont été invités cette
tanière
c'est vraiment une expérience de deux
parcours du dirigeant une transformation
de soi profonde qui encourage justement
à oser et à ouvrir ce champ des
possibles je pense qu'il est urgent
aujourd'hui pour tous et pour la planète
d'avancé différemment c'est pour ça que
nous aussi au cjd on a décidé de prendre
des positions le cjd a récemment pris
position près du gouvernement avec douze
propositions que je vais pas vous
détailler là parce que ça serait un peu
long mais sur différents axes et
notamment qui remettent en question nos
modes de consommation de production et
des changes est réaffirmée bien sûr la
nécessité de la transition économique
social et environnemental ce qui a pas
de transition environnementale sont non
plus une transition économique et social
et je pense que c'est important nous
entendre dirigeants de prendre notre
part à ces aspects là donc on a fait
différentes propositions à travers tous
et tous les champs là et je vous en
donner quelques unes par exemple sur la
partie environnement la première c'est
de proposer une cour de défense du bien
commun
on fait bien des cours de défense
européenne et aujourd'hui on n'a rien
pour protéger notre patrimoine de biens
communs donc quelque part je pense qu'il
est intéressant de monter une instance
au niveau de la protection on va dire
réglementaire réglementaires au niveau
européen au niveau français mais où
chaque citoyen dès qu'il voit une
transgression envers notre planète
pourra faire appel à cette cour de
défense pour défendre en fait notre
patrimoine à tout ce qui est bien commun
et puis il ya d'autres propositions
notamment il ya la convention il ya
beaucoup de recommandations qui ont été
faites par la convention citoyenne pour
le climat donc la convention citoyenne
pour le cne là c'est 150 citoyens qui
ont bossé pratiquement pendant deux ans
pour faire des propositions et fléchés
des solutions vers des nouveaux types
d'investissement dans des secteurs
d'avenir respectueux pour le climat et
le cjd va s'intéresser fortement à ces
propositions là et essayer de les
étudier de dégager lesquels on pourrait
mettre en exploitation dans nos
entreprises voilà quelques exemples on a
formulé une douzaine de propositions
récemment au gouvernement
on a déjà eu pas mal de retours donc on
voit que la société
les élus les maires les maires ruraux de
france nous ont des a notamment contacté
en plusieurs parlementaires à ce niveau
là et je pense que la france est en
train de bouger et c'est bien normal et
bien attendu
je vous souhaite un très bon rugby
narrer je suis très content de pouvoir
voilà lancée avec vous soit ce moment là
merci pierre et bien sans transition je
vais donner la parole directement à jean
marc jancovici pouvoir démarrer
c'est bon merci alors je vais on a enfin
les organisateurs et votre serviteur
vieux dirigeant donc remercie d'avoir
été invitée chez les petits jeunes on a
décidé que l'arbitrage de 7,2 ce temps
d'interaction seraient consacrés pour
une petite partie à quelques rappels sur
le cadrage des problèmes auxquels on
s'attaque est ensuite laissée
l'essentiel du temps à une interaction
entre nous parce que j'imagine que c'est
ça qui nous intéresse
alors pour la première partie je vais
aller assez vite si jamais il ya des
choses qui sont pas claires n'hésitez
pas à poser des questions et si vous
voulez en savoir plus l'idéal c'est de
vous renvoyer des enregistrements parce
qu'il ya de la conserve en pagaille sur
ce que je peux raconter sur la manière
dont ils se présentent et donc sur
youtube vous pourrez trouver 1 milliards
d'enregistrements de conférences qui se
ressemblent tous parce que la physique à
jacou et la même voie là et ils
détailleront ce que je vais vous
raconter maintenant et en fait je vais
vous en donner juste quelques j'ai envie
de dire quelques éléments saillants
alors voilà déjà que vous avez un très
beau truc à la matrix
on doit arriver le machin qui
m'intéresse vraiment voilà alors le
premier fait saillant que je voudrais
rappeler c'est que l'accord de paris n'a
pas pu se régler le problème du climat
que les négociations qui a eu lieu avant
et que les négociations durent eu lieu
depuis la manière de s'en rendre compte
c'est de regarder la façon dont évolue
dans l'atmosphère la quantité la
proportion de dioxyde de carbone qui se
trouve qui est en gros le niveau du
thermostat qui conditionnera le
réchauffement climatique à suivre donc
là vous êtes en train de regarder cette
cour de rouge c'est la façon dont le
thermostat remonte année après année qui
engendrera évidemment à un réchauffement
à suivre vrai que déjà totalement arrivé
alors sur cette courbe qui démarre en
l'occurrence l'année de ma naissance
mais c'est par hasard vous voyez que à
ce moment là il y avait un peu moins de
trois cent vingt millionième donc 0 0 3
2 % de co2 dans l'atmosphère s'est pas
beaucoup mais la part
d'hormones mâles ou femelles dans votre
organisme est encore plus fait que ça et
ça suffit à faire des effets extrêmement
notable sur la façon dont on nous décrit
donc il ya des tas de l'espèce chimiques
dans la nature où il suffit de
proportion très faible pour avoir des
effets très importants
c'est pas quelque chose qui est
inhabituel donc ce que vous voyez là
c'est qu'il y avait 3 118 millionième le
co2 dans l'atmosphère en 1962 et crac
crac ça monte
et s'il vous plaît
les moments où ont eu lieu les
négociations internationales vous voyez
en 1995 c'est la première réunion des
parties première réunion de pays
signataires de la convention climat qui
soit dit en passant ce s'est tenu à
berlin sous la présidence de madame
merkel
vous voyez qui se passe rien de
différent après qu'avant le protocole de
kyoto
même motif même punition copenhague qui
parait-il était un gros échec
en fait ça n'a rien changé sur la courbe
n'est pas plus que paris donc en fait ce
qui se passe depuis que on a commencé à
identifier le problème c'est que comme
le dit très bien christine berg dont on
pourra reparler nous ne sommes pas en
train de faire suffisamment peu ou trop
peu nous ne faisons rien rien du tout et
on parlera peut-être après du plan de
relance de l'économie française
on est toujours sur cette lignée de on
ne fait rien de significatif
la deuxième chose que je veux vous
montrer la est quelque chose qu'il faut
vraiment avoir en tête parce que c'est
un fait extrêmement important dans la
gestion du changement climatique dans la
manière dont vous gérez vos entreprises
et donc moi je tente de gérer celle que
je partage avec mes associés
on pense en général que quand on prend
une décision les faits se voit un peu
plus tôt que vingt ans après et bien en
ce qui concerne le climat
nous sommes en train de gérer une
entreprise climatique ou n'importe
quelle décision que nous prenons
aujourd'hui reste invisible pendant 20
ans c'est ça qu'il faut avoir en tête
ce que vous voyez sur cette courbe c'est
la variation de la température
planétaire par rapport à 1 0 de
référence qui était la moyenne en 1850
la température planétaire de l'année 850
et vous voyez que cette température
planétaire pourquoi pas avant parce
qu'avant on n'a pas assez de thermomètre
pour faire ce genre d'exercice le
thermomètre bat de 492 donc il faut en
avoir suffisamment sur terre pour
commencer à faire une moyenne donc ce
que vous voyez c'est que la température
bouge pas beaucoup
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle qu'elle
commence à monter puis elles montrent de
plus en plus vite
est ce que vous voyez là pour l'avenir
c'est la manière dont ça pourrait monter
en fonction des scénarios d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre qui sont évidemment
très discriminer aulas dans une ère où
on est mais très peu donc on aimait
beaucoup et c est vous et pour les 20
ans qui viennent ça ne change absolument
tous les scénarios nous emmène sur une
trajectoire de hausse qu'ils sont
exactement exactement la même pour les
20 ans à venir
et ça c'est dû au fait que le co2 est un
gaz qui est chimiquement inerte une fois
qu'il est dans l'atmosphère il en ai
vécu très lentement au contact du sol et
de l'océan et donc le réchauffement à
venir sur les vingt ans au réchauffement
pardon qui va survenir sur les vingt ans
sont devant nous est totalement embarqué
pour les émissions passées donc c'est
comme pour votre entreprise
il se passe quelque chose qui est
totalement indifférent à n'importe
quelle décision que vous pouvez prendre
aujourd'hui pour les 20 ans qui viennent
ça fait strictement aucune différence et
vous voyez que de toute façon les 2
degrés de hausse on va les taper dans
aller d'ici à ce que but et mon âge même
avant donc il va se passer des choses
très disruptive dans notre système
climatique parce qu'aujourd'hui d'une
somme car à degré quelqu'un dans les 20
ans qui viennent
de toute façon quoi qu'on fasse pour
comprendre à quel point quelques degrés
de variation c'est important il ya une
carte que j'aime bien qui est celle ci
là vous voyez les écosystèmes que nous
avons en europe à la fin du xxème siècle
comme dit actuelle c'est déjà je suis
déjà un peu ça déjà un peu changé à
partir du moment où on ne les supprime
pas pour faire autre chose qui a plus
d'intérêt pour nous essentiellement des
cultures dont vous voyez que l'europe
est essentiellement peuplée de grosses
d'espèces végétales c'est à dire des
arbres qui sont différents évidemment
selon que vous êtes au sud au milieu au
nord là et là il fait trop froid ou trop
sec
on met deux pour que vous ayez des armes
voilà à quoi ressemble l'europe il ya
vingt mille ans à une époque où elle est
beaucoup plus froides qu'aujourd'hui
parce que le climat planétaire a
toujours changé quand les hommes
n'étaient pas là pour tripoter c'est
juste une vitesse de variation des
variations de change et donc il ya 20 me
dans le cadre des changements
climatiques naturels l'europe était
beaucoup plus froides qu'aujourd'hui
alors la première différence majeure
c'est que vous n'avez pas d'équivalent
cjd en suède parce que là si les suédois
sont sous la glace que les allemands
nous enquiquine pas avec leur charbon
parce qu'elles sont sous la glace
vous voyez que les écossais et les
irlandais cesse d'être une nuisance pour
le tournoi des six nations parce qu'ils
sont sous la glace aussi et que les
lyonnais ont la chance de pouvoir aller
skier en bas de chez eux
le lyonnais beaucoup de ce qui à
l'époque le il ya une énorme calotte qui
s'est également constitué sur le canada
qui est aussi épaisse que cette marque
fait trois kilomètres d'épaisseur sur
les québécois et les gens de l'alberta
la colombie-britannique et pour
constituer ses énormes calotte de glace
il a fallu prendre l'eau quelques par
lots qui a servi à faire c'est qu'on
glaçons vient de l'océan ce qui a eu un
transfert par évaporation précipitation
et le niveau de l'océan a baissé de 120
m parce qu'il ya beaucoup moins d'eau à
l'intérieur le climat étant beaucoup
plus froid il est beaucoup plus sec et
les écosystèmes installés en europe à
cette époque là ressemble à ce qu'on a
au nord de la sibérie et dans ce genre
de paysage nous arriver à faire vivre un
petit arrondissement parisien sur
l'ensemble de la france où quelque 3
fois la population de cahors donc vous
avez une population humaine c'est-à-dire
en bout de chaîne alimentaire qui n'est
pas extrêmement développé le
réchauffement planétaire puisque c'en
est un qui a permis à l'europe de passer
de cet état là à cet état là et
uniquement un réchauffement de 5° en
diminuant donc là vous avez le résultat
d'une expérience que la nature a fait
pour nous dans le passé avec des
créances grandeur nature les sens du
terme qui nous montre le genre de
résultats que vous avez quand vous
réchauffer le climat de 5° enfin vous le
climat se réchauffe de 5° en dix mille
ans le genre modifications de
l'environnement
on obtient donc ce que je vais vous dire
à partir de maintenant c'est des
déclinaisons une conclusion générale qui
est quelques degrés de hausse en un
siècle 4,5 degrés de hausse en un siècle
en gros conclusion qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est que ça sera la guerre
absolument partout le retour de la
guerre et la barbarie est évidemment la
démocratie aura disparu c'est ça après
une énorme pression sur la taille de la
population humaine son espérance de vie
bref on est vraiment en train de jouer
avec le feu on n'est pas du tout en
train de parler de justesse que les
terrasses de restaurants vont rouvrir en
train de parler de quelque chose qui est
infiniment plus grave que ça alors
quelques conclusions très rapide pas
quelques détails ici vous avez une carte
qui vous donne le nombre de jours par an
où il sera impossible de se tenir en
conditions extérieures dans le monde si
les réchauffer de 4 degrés vous voyez
que ça concerne essentiellement des
zones équatoriales les endroits où vous
pourrez plus vous tenir en extérieur
pour 300 ou 350 ça
pas tous les jours de l'année et c'est
dû à un effet de température humide
quand l'air est saturé d'humidité à 100%
votre peau ne peut pas évaporée de dons
parce que l'air est déjà saturé d'eau et
dont vous ne pouvez pas refroidir votre
corps en évaporant et si la température
devient supérieures à 35 degrés et la
température de votre peau avec une
humilité de 100%
vous ne payez plus refroidir votre corps
et vous mourrez d'hyperthermie voilà
c'est ça le bain une personne en bonne
santé
c'est pas comme avec le co vite il est
juste vieux walad donc là vous avez les
zones dans le monde où il sera
essentiellement impossible de vivre avec
un petit noir et geof est de 4 degrés
dans toute l'inde
il ya une autre éducation qui vient de
sortir avec un team a réchauffé de 4,2 à
et même trois et demi vous aurez une
température annuelle moyenne qui sera
supérieur à ce qu'on a dans une partie
du sahara aujourd'hui ça ça met en jeu
des milliards d'individus qui pourront
pas rester là où ils sont qui bien
évidemment vont se mettrent ailleurs
resteront pas sur place en crever la
gueule ouverte et donc ils vont aller se
mettre ailleurs bras jamais très loin de
chez eux mais ça va des déplacements
massifs de population seront des
conflits massif de façon absolument
claire
le prêt de chez nous voilà comment vont
évoluer va évoluer l'humidité des sols
du bassin méditerranéen alors cette
courbe est un peu compliqué à lire mais
elle est en fait je vais vous
l'expliquer donc voyez pour cette zone
là qui s'appelle le bassin méditerranéen
vous avez ici en noir l'hypothèse
centrale d'évolution de l'humidité des
sols en fonction de l'élévation
planétaire de température donc ce que
vous voyez ce que pour une température
qui s'élève de 1° les sols sont déjà
moins humide à peu près 10% pour 2
degrés d'à peu près 20 % pour 3 degrés
d'à peu près 30% et la barre grise est
ici c'est l'incertitude sur ce genre
d'évaluation
ce que vous voyez ces cadeaux degré ça
pourrait être si on a de la chance - 10
mais si on n'a pas de chance c'est déjà
moins 30
or d une humidité des sols oui ça
concerne toute la partie sud de la
france qui baisse de 30% ces des
rendements agricoles qui s'effondre et
donc bien évidemment une population qui
sera plus difficile à nourrir ajoutez à
cela que au même horizon de temps on
aura de moins en moins d'énergie
abondante et que c'est ça qui lui a
permis d'avoir les tracteurs et les
engrais qui ont été le facteur central
d'augmentation de la productivité de
l'agriculture depuis la dernière guerre
mondiale vous et dans le nord de
l'europe ça sera plutôt l inverse il se
met à pleuvoir
plus donc les suédois et les finlandais
eux ils sont contents et vraiment on
peut voir plus mais ça leur fera par
ailleurs plus d'inondations
ici vous avez un graphique qui vient du
dernier rapport du giec en or des
derniers rapports du giec qui s'appelle
changement climatique et r et c'est la
barre de droite ou j'attire votre
attention
le code couleur qui est sûr c'est bart
c'est que quand vous rentrez dans le
violet vous avez des conséquences
irréversibles et généralisée est ce que
dit le giec c'est qu'à partir de 2
degrés et demi 3 degrés vous aurez une
insécurité alimentaire généralisée sur
terre donc j'en reviens à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
les gens se battront partout alors si on
ne veut pas de ce paysage apocalyptique
parce qu'il s'agit bien d'un paysage
apocalyptique il s'agit pas encore une
fois d'une récession de 10% qui nous
paraîtra une plaisanterie
au regard de ce genre de choses et bien
voilà ce qu'il faut faire et compte tenu
de l'inertie du co2 dont une fois qu'il
faut s'y prendre très très longtemps à l
avance
voilà la manière dont on peut décrire
l'effort à mener ici vous avez une
courbe qui vous décrit le lien qui
existe entre la quantité totale de co2
qu'on met dans l'atmosphère entre 1850
et 2100 je te comme le loup est très
stable c'est la quantité totale qu'on va
rajouter 30
et là vous avez une élévation de
température qui en découle entre 1850 et
2100 sachant que cette élévation de
température est le marqueur d'un
désordre généralisé qui est d'autant
plus important que vous montez et c'est
pas proportionnel de degrés de
réchauffement c'est pas deux fois plus
grave qu'un degré si ça se trouve c'est
50 fois ou deux cents fois plus graves
est ce que vous voyez c'est que donc
cette élévation de température
elle répond de façon à peu près linéaire
à la quantité totale de co2 que naîtront
dans l'atmosphère alors à fin 2010 8 on
a déjà mis un peu plus de 2000 milliards
de tonnes de co2 dans l'atmosphère et ça
veut dire que nous avons déjà signé pour
1 25 degrés en fait aujourd'hui les 1,5
degré ils sont déjà totalement embarqué
dans les émissions passées et pour se
limiter à 5 degrés en 2100 il faudrait
qu'à partir de 2050 non seulement on
émettre plus de co2 mais on en soustrait
en est à l'atmosphère tous les ans kazim
fois c'est pareil que le plus
d'économies
malheureusement sur ce pari glauque on
n'y arrivera jamais
si on veut se limiter à 2 degrés ça
c'est physiquement encore possible mais
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on limites
aux émissions à 3000 milliards de tonnes
jusqu'en 2100
son cumul est alors qu'on en a déjà émis
2200 donc ça veut dire qu'il nous en
reste 800 fait 550 à émettre et ça veut
dire en d'autres termes que d'ici à ce
que mes enfants et mon âge ici est ce
que mes enfants et mon âge dans les
générations futures je les croise tous
les jours il faut diviser les émissions
planétaires par trois alors tous ceux
d'entre vous qui ont affaire à un
banquier ou qui sont banquiers eux-mêmes
savent très bien faire des intérêts
composés
une division par trois entre maintenant
et 2050 ça veut dire des émissions qui
doit baisser de 4% par an 4 % par an 4 %
de baisse c'est à peu près ce que le
monde va faire a volontairement cette
année à cause de l'épisode qu'ovide donc
ça veut dire que si on est sérieux sur
les 2 degrés il faut qu'on est
l'équivalent d'un qu'ovide
supplémentaires tous les ans en termes
de freinage de l'activité pour limiter
le réchauffement à 2 degrés c'est ça
qu'il faut que vous gardiez enquête
alors question devant serez tout ça
c'est pourquoi est ce que l'on s'amuse à
émettre de plus en plus alors on fait
qu'on s'amuse à émettre de plus en plus
tout simplement parce que nous utilisons
de plus en plus d'énergie et notamment
d'énergie fossile oui ici la quantité
totale d'énergie qu'on n'oublie sur
terre depuis un siècle et demi voyez que
l'essentiel c'est les énergies fossiles
charbon pétrole gaz et que dans cette
histoire les énergies décarbonées
hydroélectricité nucléaire et nouvelles
énergies renouvelables ne sont pas
extrêmement importante et les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables dont on nous
parle tant voyez que c'est les moins
importante des trois que je viens
d'évoquer ce que vous voyez également
c'est que la quantité totale d'énergie
qu'ont été mis sur terre n'a pas vu son
évolution infléchie en d'une quelconque
manière par le fait que l'économie se
serait tertiarisée où l'économie se
serait dématérialisée grâce au numérique
tout ça est en fait c'est des slogans
médiatique c'est absolument pas des
réalités physiques
alors oui je compte utilisent de plus en
plus d'énergie tout simplement parce que
l'énergie c'est la nourriture des
machines et ça nous permet d'alimenter
de plus en plus de machines et
l'ensemble de ses machines nous a permis
de devenir iron man pour de vrai c'est
pour ça que nous utilisons de plus en
plus de machines parce que nous adorons
nous offrir de plus en plus de choses
donc ironman que nous avons construit
grâce à l'énergie et bien sa main gauche
c'est par exemple cette prétendue dire
qui à démultiplier la puissance de batna
1 par 100 villes où un million notre
pied gauche c'est cette voiture qui à
démultiplier la puissance de nos jambes
par 500 hommes
il a notre pied droit c'est ce camion
qui à démultiplier la puissance de nos
jambes par plusieurs milliers ce
satellite
il voit beaucoup plus loin que notre
oeil donc c'est l'oeil d'iron man la
main qui est ici c'est le tractopelle
qui est la raclée puissants comme dit
bill et c'est donc voilà toutes ces
machines
en fait c'est des morceaux d'iron man
alors évidemment ça fait pas que la clac
clac avec la lumière blanche centre mais
c'est exactement ça on s'est constitué
un costume d'iron man avec toutes ces
machines qui utilisent de l'énergie
est ce qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la puissance totale des
machines installées sur terre elle est à
tout instant 200 fois supérieur à la
puissance des muscles de l'humanité donc
c'est les machines qui produisent c'est
pas du tout les hommes
la raison pour laquelle la productivité
du travail a augmenté ce parce que les
machines se sont mises à bosser à notre
place pas parce que nous a poussés des
bras et des jambes et l'énergie c'est
donc la manière pour nous de devenir des
surhommes
c'est pour ça qu'on en utilise de plus
en plus et que c'est vachement dur parce
qu il était l de moins en moins alors
l'énergie 100% renouvelable qui est
quelque chose auquel on peut penser en
disant bon très bien on va la rendre
renouvelables il faut se rappeler que
c'est le monde dont on sort voici un
paysage où toute l'énergie et est
renouvelable
il ya quelques siècles vous voyez ici
des transports totalement renouvelable
un cheval renouvelables qui mangent de
l'herbe renouvelables qui est de temps
en temps un petit côté qu'un bateau en
bois renouvelable si vous avez une
barque en bois renouvelables poussé par
un marin renouvelables en fin d'atelier
renouvelables avec une perche en bois
renouvelables il n'y a pas de moulins
qui est sûr ce paysage m'enfin vous
aviez un moulin à vent fait en lin et en
bois que ce soit en a un en bois
renouvelables lui par le camp audois
l'histoire donc le monde des énergies
renouvelables c'est le monde dont on
sorte parce que c'est le monde vers
lequel on ira à 8 milliards d'individus
rêvant du pib par personne
on a aujourd'hui pas une seconde mais
j'y reviendrai enfin si j'ai envie
slogan publicitaire c'est bien les
énergies fossiles qui ont fait notre
puissance regardez ici la reconstitution
du pib mondial depuis la naissance de
monsieur jésus-christ a lancé ma porte
vous voyez que tant qu'on n'a pas
d'énergie fossile n a pas de croissance
et lui arrive d d'énergie fossile c'est
à dire de câbles etc annick et crack
on a ce qu'on croit être la croissance
structurelle de long terme qui bien
évidemment est un leurre nous n'aurons
pas de croissance structurelle de long
terme elle durera aussi longtemps que
durera la croissance de
l'approvisionnement en énergie qui
permet d'augmenter de puissance
mécanique
à très court terme c'est exactement ça
qu'on constate très court terme c'est
depuis que je suis née vous voyez ici là
le pib mondial en fonction de l'énergie
utilisée c'est à dire du parc de
machines en service est ce que vous
voyez c'est que pib mondial est en gros
il fonctionne linéaire du parc de
machines en service donc si on veut
moins d'énergies fossiles parce qu'on
veut moins de co2 eh bien ça va être
très très dur parce que pour le moment
comme l'essentiel de l'énergie fossile
et bien le pib mondial est aussi une
fonction linéaire en gros des émissions
de co2 donc beaucoup moins de co2 sans
récession on n'y arrivera pas donc si on
veut sauver le climat
malheureusement on va être obligé de
choisir de rentrer en récession si on
choisit pas de rentrer en récession on
ne sauvera pas le climat et on va tous
retirer plus exactement on va finir dans
la barbarie
donc on a aujourd'hui un double problème
sur terre on a un problème de pâques
artistes ville moi j'en ai pas trop
parler parce que le pétrole pendant son
fait régulier et puis il ya d'autres
sources il pendant sa frugalité aussi et
on april de poubelles qui débordent
si on met en perspective tout ce que
j'ai à vous raconter très très
rapidement donc en fait on est à la
croisée des chemins
à supposer qu'on n'ait pas déjà dépassé
ou bien on dit tant que la fête dure
allez je vais monter dans le rail de
coke et on verra bien après et à ce
moment on part vers des perturbations
environ talent environnemental majeur
qui seront très au delà de nos capacités
de gestion ou bien on décide qu'on n'en
veut pas et à ce moment où se met
immédiatement au régime de manière
extrêmement sévère et pour reprendre le
titre de cette clyde la vitesse à
laquelle il faut baisser les émissions -
4 % par an dans le monde et en france au
titre de la loi de qualité qui a été
votée l'année dernière c'est plutôt -7 à
-8% par an donc en gros c'est la
récession constr en sept années
supplémentaires tous les ans c'est à peu
près ça eh bien ça veut dire une mise au
régime extrêmement rapide qui n'est pas
compatible avec autre chose qu'une
économie tnt autrement c'est absolument
pas le monde libéralisé d'aujourd'hui
qui sera capable de gérer un effort de
cette nature à supposer qu'on souhaite
voilà donc c'est ça le dilemme dans
lequel nous sommes
et pour finir cette intervention on est
au début de la deuxième partie de notre
pacte faustien pour ceux d'entre vous
qui se rappelle faust donc au début
c'est vachement sympa on a fact is et
avec le diable le diable a dit allez je
te donne marguerite tués dans les
délices etc
et puis après il ya un moment où quand
même le diable ne pas se chercher l'âme
qu'on lui a promise
là ça commence à devenir nettement moins
là malheureusement nous commençons à
arriver à la deuxième partie de
l'histoire
il dépend encore un peu de nous mais il
faut vraiment pas perdre de temps que
cette deuxième partie soit plus ou moins
agréables et désagréables réserve de
l'espoir où on regarde de moins en moins
voilà je m'arrête là merci jean nat pour
ces nouvelles peu réjouissantes
je viens d'avoir un problème technique
avec mon écran je vais devoir rendre une
arrivée du moteur est ce que lionel tu
peux prendre le relais pour poser les
premières questions s'il te plait je
vais redémarrer le navigateur
sinon choisi celle qui plaît aussi
beaucoup mais qui est là je vais prendre
l'une des premières qui a été posée si
vous étiez le futur président national
du cjd
alors là en plus vous ne peux pas me
soupçonner d'une quelconque manoeuvre
électorale puisqu'il ya longtemps que
j'ai des cas c'est la visite d'âge pour
devenir
quelles actions proposeriez-vous je
proposerai de la formation je pense que
c'est la première chose que vous pouvez
décider de manière unilatérale c'est à
dire sans que personne ne vous le
demande sans qu'aucune réglementation de
moulins pause et sans que ça vous coûte
très cher au début la formation elle
doit porter sur deux choses elle doit
porter sur la compréhension du problème
donc là je vous en ai servi pour 20
minutes je faisais un peu sapé le moral
c'est important quand même de bien
comprendre le problème auquel on
s'attaque parce que on est dans une
course contre la montre et on aura pas
deux essais déjà on a partiellement
gâché une partie du premier essai donc
c'est essentiel de bien comprendre le
problème auquel on s'attaque
si vous arrivez chez le médecin et que
le médecin est intimement persuadé que
vous avez une verrue alors vous avez un
cancer la probabilité qu'il nous soit
dit à peu près nulles donc il vaut mieux
savoir de quoi on parle
la deuxième chose que je crois utile
c'est de s'équiper d'un système de
pilotage face aux problèmes donc le
déploiement de tous qui regroupe
comptabilité carbone stratégie de degré
etc
alors ça peut être un peu rustique au
début mais il faut se poser la question
de savoir où va son entreprise si on
fait des cartonnages des fleurs coupées
ou que l'on fait de la publicité dans un
monde dans lequel le pib se contracte
et où on à telle ou telle modification
profonde qui survient voilà donc je
crois que c'est vraiment le domaine qui
peut rassembler tout le monde parce que
cela ne suppose pas d'avoir des mesures
sectorielles
cela ne suppose pas de brimer qui que ce
soit ça suppose juste de rendre les gens
plus intelligents et j'espère que les
adhérentes demande
je pense que c'est la première chose que
j'essaierai de favoriser c'est ça si
jeanne d'arc dit que je ne sais pas
quelles questions vous avez répondu mais
c'est pas ça lui arrive elle terre qui
disait si vous étiez le futur président
national du cjd quelques actions
proposeriez vous voilà alors autre
question du coût en tant que chef
d'entreprise comment intégrer l'idée de
décroissance c'est très difficile parce
que une entreprise est une activité de
conquête toujours la mienne comme les
vôtres carbone 4 j'entends pas avoir des
effectifs qui se réduisent et des
clients qui partent comme peau de
chagrin
ne serait ce que parce que je crois que
ce que je fais est utile et que c'est
rare les chefs d'entreprise qui se
disent je vends de la merde et ce que je
fais n'a strictement aucun intérêt
il y en a quelques-uns évidemment qui
sont au-delà de ça tout simplement parce
qu'ils se foutent de savoir si c'est
utile ou pas utile mais à nouveau je ne
suis pas pour ce que j'ai vu du cjd je
suis pas complètement persuadés que ce
soit la totalité de l'état d'esprit des
adhérents même s'il ya toujours quelques
fils ou partie donc le donc c'est très
difficile eux ce qui est après ça dépend
énormément du secteur dans lequel on
n'est pas ce que tous les secteurs ne
vaut pas dégringoler à la même vitesse
dans cet univers là il ya quand même
quelque chose qui s'appelle la pyramide
des besoins
il ya quand même quelque chose qui
s'appelle la destruction créatrice
chercheurs ne se shoote petter et donc
les on va pas souffrir de la même
manière selon qu'on produit les patates
ou qu'on vend des vols pour les
seychelles donc est du reste en ce
moment les gens qui font les deux ne
souffre pas du tout de la même manière
voilà ce qui est très difficile d'une
manière générale c'est de se faire à
l'idée qu'on va faire partie des
perdants
jamais personne n'accepte de faire ça
c'est très très difficile
ski
est plus facile c'est d'essayer d'être
moins surpris si on a un coup du sort
ça c'est facile donc j'en reviens à ce
que je disais sur se renseigner et puis
essayer de piloter au mieux sa barque
pour réorienter son activité en se
disant qu on essaye de se déplacer vers
un secteur où on se dit que la finalité
ne pas assurer dans le monde de demain
vers un hiver un secteur où on se dit
qu'elle est un peu plus mais c'est
évident que c'est un jeu qui se joue
dans un contexte qui devient très
différent de celui dans lequel on a joué
dans le passé et j'ai moi même à ce
stade pas la réponse à toutes les
questions
merci je remarque faut y réfléchir
en gros à part dire vous êtes des gens
intelligents font réfléchir il n'y a pas
grand chose d'autre à répondre et là on
voit que les gens se collective peut
avoir son intérêt sur il faut en parler
il ya aussi un sujet d'examen il faut
exorciser ce genre de trucs ces sujets
difficiles dans ces déserts herbe dont
il faut parler pour faire des
psychothérapies groupe sur ce genre de
trucs alors question suivante quels sont
les trois mesures concrètes que vous
mettriez immédiatement en place pour
réduire le co2 si vous étiez le patron
de l'union européenne le président de la
république le président d'une région il
y en a beaucoup plus de 3 le shift
project est en train de réfléchir en ce
moment à ce que serait un plan de
transformation de l'économie française
à la faveur de la grande claque combien
se prendre en espérant que ça un peu
ouvert les esprits sur le fait que les
mauvaises surprises c'était possible et
donc pour qu'on ne reparte pas
exactement comme avant alors je peux
vous livrer par exemple les mesures
qu'on a proposé dans le domaine aérien
puisqu'elles sont que de fraîche date
d'hier pourquoi l'aérien parce que c'est
le premier secteur qui est allé toucher
un chèque et donc c'est le premier
secteur auquel on s'est intéressés pour
savoir quelles étaient les contreparties
qui lui paraissait légitime au fait de
toucher un chantier c'est juste ça le
sujet alors je vous donne un exemple on
a proposé de supprimer toutes les
liaisons domestiques qui étaient
desservies à moins de quatre heures
trente de trains ainsi que toutes les
liaisons intra européennes qui étaient
desservies à moins de quatre heures
prendre le train donc par exemple paris
genève paris zurich paris amsterdam
paris ou londres
on a proposé de supprimer les jets
privés sauf pour motifs humanitaires et
gouvernementaux on a proposé de
décarbonés la totalité alors supprimer
ça vient supprimer les slots et pas
supprimée pour air france si on supprime
les créneaux de décollage et
d'atterrissage
c'est ça le sujet on a proposé d'imposer
aux compagnies aériennes sous peine de
leur supprimer les créneaux de décollage
et d'atterrissage une baisse à marche
forcée de la quantité de carburant
qu'elle utilise et on a proposé de
décarbonés totalement les opérations au
sol des aéroports par exemple en
supprimant l'utilisation des groupes
auxiliaires qui utilise du kérosène pour
fournir l'électricité à l'avion quand il
est c
on a également proposé de réaménager de
faire plus d'écho au moins deux
premières et business dans les avions
parce que ce qu'on soit beaucoup plus
par passager en business et en première
et enfin on propose également de
supprimer les maïs nominatif en ce qui
concerne les entreprises
si vous avez des miles et pour
l'entreprise pas pour vous alors en fait
on peut pas proposer de les supprimer je
crois que ça c'est pas légal mais on
peut proposer de les considérer comme
les avantages en nature
donc il voulait récupérer comme des
avantages en nature c'est fiscalisés et
socialiser donc vous payez des impôts et
des charges sociales dessus voilà ce
qu'on a proposé et on a empilé toutes
les mesures pour être en phase avec ce
que je disais tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que l'on veut que les émissions de
l'aérien en baisse de 4% par an à partir
demain matin
ce qui veut dire que sur cinq ans il
faut gratter d'un pour cent donc on a
pris les émissions liées au carburant
qui était servi en france on a fait
moins 20 % sur les cinq ans qui viennent
et on a empilé tout ce que je vous ai
raconté jusqu'au moment où on y arrive
ça c'est pas faire des plans sur la
comète avec lannion à hydrogène qui
arrivera quand je serai mort et j'ai pas
quoi c'est demain matin on agit parce
qu'il ya le feu au lac
alors voilà c'est pas la réponse à la
question qui était posée mais c'est
quand même ma réponse comme disait
l'autre
le père marché le sens de ces le type de
raisonnement qu'il faut adopter donc ce
n'est pas une mesure
c'est un programme complet c'est sale
c'est ça le sujet c'est un projet
aujourd'hui je considère que nous
n'avons pas de projet réduire le déficit
budgétaire en dessous de 3% c'est une
contrainte c'est pas un projet 3 et une
personne dans la rue
prenez n'importe lequel de vos
collaborateurs en dix ans le projet de
la france et de baisser le déficit
budgétaire en dessous de 3%
est ce que ça vous fait bander je pense
pas qu'il y en a beaucoup qui vont vous
dire oui pas vraiment un truc qui
enthousiasme les foules
c'est pas un projet du reste personne
dans son entreprise me dit mon projet
c'est d'éviter la perte de l'entreprise
à 3% de son chiffre d'affaires suis
contrainte mais c'est sûrement pas un
projet donc aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
de projet est en fait décarbonés
l'économie quand vous regardez lien
comme l'énergie a tout fait c'est un
projet donc ce n'est pas une mesure
c'est un programme total cohérence
stratégique et qui va porter sur un
siècle
alors après ça peut se décliner de plein
de manières je vous invite si ça vous
intéresse à lire les propositions qu'on
va sortir au chiffre parce que ça sera
des propositions mises en débat
évidemment
alors ça va être un peu hard 1 pour
certaines donc là je viens de vous en
donner un exemple sur le secteur aérien
et la bonne question à chaque fois et là
j'espère ne pas choquer les actionnaires
que vous êtes mais j'en suis un aussi la
question à chaque fois sera pas de temps
qu'est-ce qu'on fait du capital mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des gens
dit autrement l'actionnaire il prend le
risque de perdre ses actions c'est vous
vous êtes chef d'entreprise est
actionnaire de votre entreprise
jamais l'état n'a passé avec vous un
contrat qui on vous garantit votre
capital l'état a passé avec vous un
contrat qui on vous autorise à risquer
votre argent et qui s'agace a gagné
temps en temps ça perd sa paire moi
c'est pareil demain matin je peux perdre
de l'argent que j'ai dans cars 2 4 et
jamais personne la garantie ça a dit
amsterdam
donc ce qui est important dans cette
histoire c'est pas de garantir le
capital c'est de garantir l'emploi des
gens et donc ce qui est vraiment
important c'était de savoir ce qu'on
fait des gens et c'est toute la question
des compétences et de les gens qui n'ont
plus d'avenir dans le secteur aérien
qu'est ce qu'on leur fait faire c'est ça
c'est ça la bonne question que air
france
les actionnaires d'air france perdent
leur argent ils ont pris le risque voilà
ainsi soit il me survivra
voilà donc cesser je pense qu'il faut
vraiment raisonnée maintenant on n'a
plus le temps de raisonner
avec des trucs qui sont trop tranquille
il faut vraiment y aller avec quelque
chose qui ressemble à un plan d'urgence
parce que vraiment les problèmes vont
arriver beaucoup plus vite que l'idée
qu'on s'en fait au plus vite que l'idée
qu'on s'en fait du coup pour rebondir
les tous ces sujets que vous proposez
vous est proposé uniquement sur la
france
ou alors pour quel niveau en fait alors
on l'est on les a proposées au niveau
des gens qui ont les mains sur les
manettes et au niveau des gens auprès de
qui on a une chance d'être audible donc
là aussi on a eu un raisonnement très
pragmatique de chef d'entreprise
madame von der leyen ne sait pas que
j'existe et je pense qu'elle mourra sans
savoir que j'existe donc on pour le
moment on commence par s'attaquer au
gouvernement français qui lui le sait un
peu plus
parce que là on a des relais en france
des gens qui peuvent dire que ce qu'on
propose n'est pas idiot fait sens
correspond à une logique et c est le
chip project depuis son origine travail
en fait énormément ses contacts avec le
monde économique parce que c'est un
monde de gens qui savent calculer donc
ils savent faire une règle de trois et
savent qu'à un moment on n'y échappe pas
même si c'est dur qu'à un moment on n'y
échappe pas
donc on a décidé de s'attaquer à ce
public là au sens de leur parler
travailler avec eux est ce qu'on cherche
à faire c'est à s'appuyer sur les gens
qui disent que tout ça n'est pas idiot
et notamment parce que ça peut être bon
pour leur propre activité pour essayer
de faire passer quelque chose qui nous
paraît pertinent pour la collectivité
c'est ça notre notre stratégie depuis le
début on a la possibilité de trouver de
l'écho en france aujourd'hui en europe
très peu on n'est pas assez puissant on
n'est pas assez connu on n'a pas de
bureau à bruxelles
et c'est donc ce qu'on essaye de faire
c'est du billard à de grandes
c'est à dire d'abord essayé de réveiller
les français et si les français disent
que tout ça fait sens pour un grand
projet politique pour l'europe
à ce moment on espère qu'il y aura une
partie des dirigeants français qui
feront entendre cette voix là auprès de
l'europe dans son ensemble parce que
l'europe n'est que la somme des pays qui
la font - sané riendeau au niveau des
régions là on est aussi face à des gens
qui sont plus accessibles puisque l'on
reste à l'échelle enfin on reste dans le
pays
mais vous les connaissez peut-être pour
certains d'entre vous ces gens qui sont
dans le monde politique
vous savez très bien que on accède à ces
gens là qu'à partir
moment où on a des positions
opérationnelles qui sont relayés par un
nombre suffisant de gens dans la société
civile dans le monde politique où
n'existait pas par leur pertinence de
vos raisonnements vous existez parce que
vous êtes capable d'en produire un
rapport de force il faut donc il faut
que le rapport de force soit introduit
par un nombre suffisant de gens dans la
société civile qui disent les petits
jeunes parce qu'il raconte c'est pas
idiot questions suivantes
le cjd et en actions tant qu est le
chief projet étant un think tank
pensez vous que une collaboration
rapprochée pour être l'aider à accélérer
la mise en oeuvre des plans de
décarbonation bar on en serait ravi
dit autrement vous ne vais pas le cacher
derrière mon petit doigt l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles je suis ravi de
vous parler ce soir c'est justement
parce que j'espère trouver des
interlocuteurs qui vont se dire que de
raisonner à partir des éléments que j'ai
exposé ses pertinents un certain nombre
d'entre vous ont des enfants
probablement à ces jeunes puisque si
vous avez moins de 40 ans se doute que
vos enfants et beaucoup plus de 20 donc
vous avez vous des gens qui d'ici à ce
qu'ils aient mon âge à moi un demi
siècle va se passer donc les problèmes
que je viens d'évoquer ce soir c'est les
problèmes de la génération de la vôtre
et de celles de vos enfants vers moi si
je meurs demain bon à 60 ans allez on
peut dire que j'ai bien profiter de la
vie vos enfants ils vont vivre
l'essentiel de leur vie d'adulte
s'ils y parviennent jusqu'à mon âge dans
un monde qui sera de plus en plus
troublé donc je pense que pour vous ça
fait sens de vous battre et vous avez un
arbitrage à faire c'est très clair ça
fait sens de vous battre
donc j'espère bien que je vais trouver
quelques relais de gens qui se diront
tiens on va essayer de regarder ce
qu'ils font ces braves gens et s'il ya
des trucs qui propose qui sont pas
idiots du tout eh bien on va voir
comment est ce que l'on pourrait avancer
ensemble sur la façon de les porter les
mettre en oeuvre
eh bien on y va alors attendez vous
n'avez pas vu le reste des mesures non
mais il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
alors un domaine par exemple donc il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire c'est
retrouver la noblesse du travail manuel
et re développer l'apprentissage
bon je ne sais pas si ça fait partie des
axes de travail du cjd alors nous on a
beaucoup milité sur les notions
d'apprentissage
faire de bataille un des grands combats
qu'on a fait et qu'on continue à mener
sur l'apprentissage et puis l'aspect
jeunesse quelque chose d'hyper
développer dans le cjd on a beaucoup
d'actions envers la jeunesse les
générations futures
moi je suis hyper convaincu mais ce que
je dis je suis hyper convaincu que c'est
aussi nous qui allons prendre les
premiers murs c'est à dire que là on en
prend un petit premier mur avec le co
vide et finalement c'est finalement la
normalité de demain
on voit bien s'affronter et donc bon on
peut continuer à prendre des murs essayé
prendre chaque année c'est bien c'est
super mais de toute façon sur
l'environnement je suis assez convaincu
comme vous qui n'a pas trop d'autres
voies par contre il ya vrai une vraie
équation a trouvé avec le social et
l'économique oui c'est ça la difficulté
en fait de l'équation qui est devant
nous c'est comment on arrive à revenir
dans un monde plus raisonnable et
socialement qui fait attention à tout le
monde parce que si leur la guerre
si l'environnement par an en bis breen
effet la fin mais il y aura la guerre
aussi fille socialement fait rien donc
d'accord les deux sens les deux sont
liés d'une part et d'autre part c'est la
raison pour laquelle nos chiffres
project on a décidé sur ce plan de
transformation de réfléchir en poule
emploi et j'en ai l'argent on verra
après les autres mais on commence par
dire qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est quoi la
maison combattit ou qu'on détruit pour
leur mettre ailleurs ou qu'on transforme
et une fois que on a défini le projet et
qu'on a défini
on avait besoin de gens et là on en aura
moins besoin ensuite on parle argent
n'est sûrement pas en premier dit
autrement dans un premier temps l'argent
on s'en fout ce qui nous ce qui compte
c'est les gens de toute façon aussi
gilbert des premiers peslier s'est
développée pour pérenniser développer
dans un monde où toute façon
on pérennise pas le monde et l'on tue il
ya aucun futur c'est ce que vous avez
très bien dit exprimé en termes
stratégiques
un dirigeant un peu ça on sait si c'est
très bien que ces entreprises n'ont
aucune à venir il va forcément pire
était forcément changer de bourg vient
intellectuellement il est obligé de le
faire sauf qu'il est suicidaire mais bon
ça c'est un autre débat avec une autre
question
l'élevage et la pêche détruisent aussi
la planète comment soutenir et
encourager les agriculteurs et les
entreprises pour organiser un changement
de l'alimentation l'air plus de végétal
et les reconversions nécessaire alors là
là la question qui est posée là est une
question extrêmement intéressante parce
qu'elle touche à plein de sujets qui
sont des sujets à la fois de long terme
est difficile
la première raison pour laquelle le
sujet est difficile c'est que
l'alimentation c'est des héritages
culturels
si vous essayez d'expliquer à un
bourguignon que le boeuf bourguignon il
ya pas qu il le met à la poubelle c'est
compliqué si vous essayez de lui
expliquer que bourgogne à boire pour le
mettre à la poubelle ça va l'être encore
plus mais heureusement bourgogne à boire
et moins carboné que le boeuf
si vous et si vous essayez d'expliquer à
un breton que le poisson c'est pas
terrible
ou pire encore que la canette c'est pas
jambon fromage c'est tout ça donc
l'alimentation séance de culturel donc
ce n'est pas ce sujet l'an est un sujet
compliqué les pratiques agricoles c'est
aussi des sujets lent et des sujets
compliqués parce que l'observation
montre les pratiques agricoles ça prend
une génération de l'échangé en gros les
gens changent quand vous renouveler
l'exploit tant c'est rare que ça change
de manière massive entre crois pas même
exploitant est installé comme si des
sujets de long terme
donc là je vais dire un premier gros mot
ça veut dire que c'est des sujets qui ne
peuvent pas être porté par une
organisation de type marché c'est ça
peut paraître très étonnant que
j'utilise cette expression pour
l'agriculture mais c'est typiquement un
domaine dans lequel on a besoin de
politiques industrielles
je veux dire par là de politique de
planification à long terme
donc on a besoin que l'état retrouve sa
vocation de planificateur de long terme
ce qui l'a été avant la grande vague
libérale qui s'est emparée de tout le
monde
depuis quelques décennies qui a été
porté par l'école de chicago et les
américains qui nous ont expliqués et
leurs alliés anglais en europe avant que
lehman anglais de foals gaza qui décide
que finalement l'état fort c'était
vachement bien ce qu'ils soient en train
de faire en ce moment c'est exactement
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire ils
sont devenus beaucoup plus dirigiste que
doux dans un certain nombre de domaines
les anglais donc cesser on a vraiment
besoin d'un état fort ce qui veut dire
d'un état qu'ils sachent où il arriva ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui je le
redis aujourd'hui il a une gestion
critiquée mais ça passe a conduit
demande alors si j'essaie d'être un peu
concrets dans les mesures en france
il faut probablement diviser le cheptel
bovin par doute
par ailleurs les éleveurs qui déjà se
suicident aujourd'hui et gagnent pas
grand chose je n'ai aucune envie de les
maltraiter parce qu'ils font un métier
beaucoup plus dur que le mien est
beaucoup plus dur que celui d'une partie
des gens qui nous écoutent
donc si on veut diviser la quantité de
kilos qu'ils produisent par deux eh bien
les traiter dans la règle de trois vous
dit qu'il faut augmenter fortement le
prix au kilo donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut créer un système de prix minimum
garanti pour les éleveurs
et pour que tout ça tienne la route il
faut mettre en face des cahiers des
charges qui font en sorte qu' on est sûr
qu'ils vont bien travaillé par exemple
n'avoir à peu près que des bêtes au
pâturage s'interdire les importations de
soja etc
mais si vous leur dites que vous
multipliez par 6 le prix au kilo il ya
aucune raison pour qu'il ne fasse pas
est une manière pour que le consommateur
accepte les fortes augmentations de prix
c'est de déplacer de développer très
fortement le système des appellations
d'origine protégée et des labels en fait
là il ya une articulation global a
trouvé dans laquelle la hausse de
qualité et directement affichées au
travers des labels et les appellations
vous garantissez on pourrait faire le
même système que dans l'électricité
d'origine renouvelable et ce serait à
mon avis beaucoup plus intelligent dans
l'agriculture que pour l'électricité en
france
problème est déjà réglé on pourrait dire
ben voilà dès que vous avez du boeuf
nature et machin etc
je vous garantie un prix minimum ou kg
qui est franco à 10 euros kg aujourd'hui
c'est un euro cinquante
par contre vous allez en faire deux fois
moins et vous allez le faire comme ceux
ci et comme cela ou avec tel ou tel
et quand vous êtes dans ce genre de
système aujourd'hui les éleveurs qui
mieux 1
les éleveurs qui font du beaufort ou du
comté vise mieux que les gens qui
vendent du lait grande distribution à
sociale
c'est absolument évident donc voilà en
gros ce qu'il faut faire sur la partie
élevage
la pêche c'est pareil il faut gérer
durablement les stocks alors là vous
avez plein de mesures mais qui sont
toujours des mesures de planification
il faut développer les aires marines
protégées peut-être la meilleure ce riz
au poisson mais ça ça commence à se
développer et même les pêcheurs
eux-mêmes reconnaissent que c'est très
bien de faire ce genre de truc et il
faut avoir des quotas avec des prix
garantis de telle sorte que ainsi vous
puissiez en plus diminuer la puissance
des armements puisque vous pêcherait -
ils gagneraient plus et vous aurez moins
de frais si vous avez des bateaux qui
sont plus petits à chaque fois on se
rend compte que dans ces problème de
long terme si on essaye de gérer le
problème par le marché on n'y arrive pas
pour que le marché ça va très bien et
que monde infini mais de marché partout
et tout le temps dans le monde fini ça
marchera pas je me garde une petite
question subsidiaire par rapport aux
estimations du cheptel titre a divisé
par deux par rapport à l'autonomie
alimentaire de la france aujourd'hui et
avec en divisant donc le cheptel par
boeckx terrain
est-ce qu'on serait plus autonome à
l'avenir moins autonomes ah bah je suis
pas tellement à preuve d'autonomie parce
que la france aujourd'hui elle sauf
erreur de ma part elle importe des
morceaux nobles on mange trop de steak
et pas assez de steaks hachés et de
pot-au-feu euros 1 donc on exportait des
bas morceaux et on importe des morceaux
nobles et l'autonomie alimentaire avec
un cheptel bovin divisé par deux depuis
aucun problème en fait ce qui va limiter
l'autonomie alimentaire des français
c'est la pluviométrie des engrais et la
mécanisation
c'est ça les salles aujourd'hui il faut
bien voir que les terres à blé par
exemple ont vu leur rendement multipliés
par 7 entre 1945 et 1975 essentiellement
grâce aux engrais azotés de synthèse et
à la mécanisation
c'est ça c'est ça qui a fait l'explosion
des rendements des rendements agricoles
alors il ya des domaines dans lesquels
ces témoins indépendants par exemple le
maraîchage s'en était moins dépendants
mais par contre pour les céréales qui
servent essentiellement à alimenter des
animaux qu'on ne mange pas en direct
ça c'est la mécanisation et les angles
donc si on avait moins de mécanisation
et moins d'engrais ce qui sera le cas
quand on aura moins d'énergies fossiles
ça veut dire que les rendements des
champs céréaliers vont baisser les
serments et donc de toutes façons ça
contraindre à la quantité de viande
qu'on peut avoir
il faut ajouter à ça qui est en plus une
concurrente visage des sols aujourd'hui
pour faire de l'énergie par exemple en
allemagne
ils ont 3 % de la surface agricole 3 %
de la surface du pays pardon qui sert à
cultiver des plantes qui vont finir dans
des méthaniseurs pour faire de
l'électricité 3 % de la superficie du
pays ça fait beaucoup
effectivement merci alors je passe à la
question suivante comment peut-on
rapidement induire une baisse de la
consommation en europe
une taxe carbone ou un quotas carbone
serait-il la solution le la taxe c'est
un instrument qui est par essence
extrêmement libérale la taxe en gros
c'est un instrument de type des verts de
toit et du reste c'est bien ça que lui
ont reproché les gilet jaune
c'est un instrument dans lequel on dit
la nuisance vaut plus cher et des maires
de toi pour trouver tout seul une
solution c'est ça la taxe alors il ya
des domaines avec lesquels ça marche
bien parce que la solution est facile à
trouver par exemple la cigarette la
solution est facile à trouver on arrête
de fumer après compliqué ça peut faire
mal mais la solution on la connaît avec
les sens c'est plus compliqué parce que
si vous habitez à 25 km de votre
domicile de votre travail c'est avant
que vivre
vous habitez à 25 km de votre travail il
est évident que si les sens mais
avaloirs trop cher pour que vous fassiez
25 km vous n'allez pas en enfer 22 en
voiture et puis descend donc finir les
trois kilomètres à pied ça veut dire que
la taxe carbone elle doit s'accompagner
nécessairement de mesures d'organisation
donc ce n'est pas une politique en tant
que tel c'est éventuellement le volet
fiscal d'une politique est par ailleurs
il ya un truc auquel il faut faire très
très attention parce que l'état
attendant sûr toujours tomber dans le
piège c'est que quand vous créez un
impôt dissuasif ne faut pas le
transformer en un pot de rendement or
c'est un problème qui est extrêmement
propre par exemple la cigarette
aujourd'hui est devenu un impôt de
rendement si les français s'arrêter
totalement de fumer demain matin et à se
faire emmerder
ils perdraient je pense combien 10 ou 20
milliards de recettes fiscales par an
pas négligeable
et c'est exactement pareil pour les
taxes sur l'essence s'il devait
atteindre les français devait totalement
vertueux et on voulait tous à
l'électricité on a 30 milliards de t
icpe qui disparaîtraient des comptes de
l'état
voilà on en est aujourd'hui on pourrait
dire quand même ça fait un paquet
d'argent donc c'est toujours très très
or l'état ne sachant pas planifier ses
recettes fiscales à long terme ne serait
ce que parce que la loi lui interdit
d'être d'avoir des recettes d'avoir un
budget qui est autre autre chose qu'à
duel c'est interdit par la loi
et bien parce que vous pouvez vous ne
pouvez pas par la loi vous imposer des
contraintes que vous pouvez pas défaire
donc le la fiscalité carbone
elle a un certain nombre d'écueils donc
ça peut être une mesure d'accompagnement
mais ça peut pas être une mesure
principale aujourd'hui et qui en plus
est un phénomène non c'est à dire que si
on devait demain matin à mettre la taxe
carbone au niveau auquel il faudrait
vraiment là m pour que ça commence à
avoir un effet significatif on parle pas
de 20 euros la tonne de co2 on parle de
500 à 2000
hélas le seuil de douleur et a pas
beaucoup trop vite je suis aujourd'hui
partisan de passer beaucoup plus par la
réglementation alors je vais vous donner
un exemple pour supprimer les chaudières
à fuel dans ce pays vous avez deux
options on irait dire je monte les prix
du fioul
et puis démerde toi la deuxième est de
dire il sera interdit de remplacer une
chaudière à fuel par une autre chaudière
à fuel si elle tombe en panne et au
moment où ça arrive
soit vous êtes john dirigeants
grassement payés et vous fait ça à vos
frais soit vous êtes la femme de ménage
ou l'homme des ménages du jeune
dirigeant payés au smic et à ce moment
l'état vous aide à un dispositif de ce
type là al'avantage d'être clair lisible
de permettre à un certain nombre de
jeunes dirigeants qui nous écoutent en
ce moment de dire ah tiens c'est pas con
ce truc là
alors moi je vais militer pour cette
réglementation puis dès qu'elle passe je
monte une entreprise pour installer des
pompes à chaleur
donc ça al'avantage d'être beaucoup plus
lisible pour le ménage beaucoup plus
lisible sur la manière dont l'activité
va se développer derrière et ça permet
de faire de la planification d'ensemble
dans laquelle on a à la fois les
compétences le geste les entreprises et
le résultat environnementale qui nous
intéresse
je peux prendre un autre exemple sur la
voiture on peut fortement limiter la
consommation des véhicules qu'on vend en
france de le faire de manière
réglementaire où on peut le faire de
manière fiscale à ce moment tout de
suite ça dit aux gens qui travaillent
dans le secteur automobile l'an c'est
plus intéressant de vendre des petites
voitures que de vente des grosses je
m'arrange en conséquence
enfin voilà ça donne des signaux qui
sont clairs et lisibles et pour revenir
à ce que je disais sur l'aérien tout à
l'heure si je dis j'interdis les
liaisons domestiques et légendaire
france j'essaye de les recaser dans le
surplus de trafic ferroviaire que ça va
engendrer
je sais à peu près quoi faire donc
effectivement ça va frotter un peu il va
y avoir des gens qui vont être un peu
perdus pendant quelques mois ou quelques
semaines mais j'ai quand même un plan
d'ensemble
je sais à peu près où je vais et c'est
beaucoup plus facile de faire ça que
dire je mets une taxe sur le kérosène
écart france se démerdent donc mettre de
la fiscalité en accompagnement encore
une fois c'est une bonne idée
par exemple si je fais des voitures à 2
litres en france où une voiture à 6
litres que dans le même temps je monte
progressivement le prix de l'essence
d'un facteur 3 pour être sûr que les
gens vont pas rouler deux fois plus ça
c'est pas une mauvaise idée mais en
faire un instrument principal
malheureusement quelque part c'est se
défausser sur les acteurs qui doivent
faire donc ça marche si on leur laisse
le temps
si vous avez un siècle devant vous ça
marche bien
si vous avez 20 ou 30 ans devant vous
malheureusement l'horizon temps devient
trop court ok merci
que pensez vous d'un système de type
revenu universel pour le volet social
bas ont signé aujourd'hui avec le
chômage partiel aller entre le chômage
partiel et les fonctionnaires payés à
rien faire en ce moment parce qu'enfin
maintenant un peu moins mais je sais
qu'il y en avait plein parce que pour
eux il n'y a pas de sujet de chômage
partiel je pense que pendant un mois
notre pays a connu un système dans
lequel 50% de la population avait le
revenu universel
pour ajouter à cela le cjd a pris
position effectivement depuis longtemps
ce revenu universel
c'est une mesure qui nous paraît
effectivement aller dans le bon sens
effectivement dans la protection sociale
notamment c'est un des instruments qui
pourrait permettre d'avoir une harmonie
sociale un peu plus dans le monde on va
en tout cas c'est un instrument qui nous
paraît efficace
alors moi je n'ai pas d'avis définitif
là dessus je pense en tout cas que ça
vaut le coup d'en discuter
il ya des sous ensembles dans lesquels
vous l'avez déjà par exemple le minimum
vieillesse est une forme de revenu
universel
le rsa est une forme de revenu universel
en pratique on en a déjà débout et les
morceaux comme diraient les anglais je
pense que c'est un vrai sujet à ce stade
je n'ai pas suffisamment creusé la
question pour avoir nom est parti d'une
expérimentation et clinton clinton
compte mener ensemble éventuellement
j'ai mal posé une question concernant la
comptabilité carbone est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous considérez comme
un préalable en fait à toute action dans
l'entreprise et est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous que vous conseillez com a
réalisé en one shot ou de toute façon de
façon continue dans les années à venir
alors non c'est comme une comptabilité
monétaire c'est à dire que c'est un
système de pilotage c'est un indicateur
de pilotage et donc à partir du moment
où on ne met en place il faut le garder
parce que on ne peut pas faire un truc
si vous faites les comptes de votre
entreprise une fois tous les 50 ans ça
va être un peu compliqué de piloter
l'action de l'entreprise
donc là c'est exactement pareil c'est un
système de pilotage il faut l'avoir en
il faut l'avoir en permanence ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est pas la peine d'en
faire trop alors ce que j'ai coutume de
dire c'est que c'est un système qui doit
être désagréger en fait ce qui est
important avec la comptabilité carbone
c'est de l'avoir désagréger au niveau
des gens qui doivent prendre des
décisions
donc si vous êtes dans une entreprise de
10 personnes vous demandez pas le même
système à mettre en place que si vous
êtes dans une entreprise de 500 ou de
3000 si vous avez une seule activité
c'est pas pareil que si vous en avez 10
si vous avez un seul pays d'importation
c'est pas pareil que s'il y en avait 10
et c'est donc c'est exactement comme une
comptabilité monétaire à ceci près que
la façon de tenir ses comptes n'est pas
la même ça répond pas à la même logique
mais une fois que vous avez mis le doigt
dedans oui c'était important c'est de
conserver de suivi de ce que vous faites
et sans en faire trop haut mais de
conserver le suivi de ce que nous fait
sentir
alors aujourd'hui il ya peu d'offres qui
sont bien adaptés aux pme parce que en
carbone 4 à une activité qui concerne
essentiellement les grands groupes temps
patrons de pme je vois très bien le
consentement à la dépense dans une pme
c'est évident qu'il n'est pas du tout le
même donc il faut mettre sur pied des
systèmes qu'ils soient simplifiées plus
accessible probablement de type saas etc
qui permettent
exactement comme moi je fais depuis un
certain temps ma compta à contacter la
société personnelle n'est pas carbone 4
c'est que j'avais avant sur un petit
logiciel en ligne ou sur sa puissance
est l'enjeu parce que les frais il faut
avoir l'équivalent développé pour les
pme on est en train d'y travailler
on y réfléchit à 44 on met pas les sols
ça serait bien qu'ils aient l'émergence
d'offres de ses peintures passe à la
question suivante en début de
confinement vous aviez dit que la chance
réelle de la risette environnementale
était non pas le plan de relance mais
son échec est toujours votre avis et
pouvez vous développer
oui alors je ce que j'ai essayé
d'expliquer à ces dans un truc qui
s'appelle un facebook live s'il ya des
gens qui ont suivi donc j'ai quelques
années il ya des gens sans que je le
sache qui ont fait une page facebook à
mon nom m'en suis rendu compte un jour
où il devait fille m'a dit ah tiens pas
une page facebook a pour nom maintenant
pardon tu as créé une page facebook la
regardons toujours pardon de quoi et en
fait c'est des gens qui avaient été ça
pour moi pour essentiellement diffuser
des informations qui sont liées à
l'énergie et au changement climatique
et que je fais enfin maintenant je me
demandais toujours pas dégeu travaillant
évidemment en étroite
on est trois liens avec les gens qui
s'en occupent et il ya je crois un an
ils m'ont dit une fois tiens il ya des
gens qui arrêtent pas de poser des
questions donc tu devrais de temps en
temps faire une session de questions
réponses
exactement comme on est en train de la
faire en ce moment là avec les gens de
la page facebook est bloqué et puis
pendant le confinement j'en ai fait
quelques-uns puisque comme on en avait
marre de regarder la télé qu'on peut
plus sortir donc les webinaires se sont
développés est une des questions qui m'a
été posée c'est qu'est ce qui va se
passer au moment du plan de relance et
j'aurais dit il va se passer qu'on va
chercher à faire repartir les activités
à l'identique pour une raison très
simple c'est que tant que vous ne s'est
pas au moment où l'incendié se déclare
que vous faites le plan d'évacuation en
cas d'incendié faut y avoir pensé avant
et comme l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir des
gros accident de parcours qui
nécessiterait de réorienter les
activités est un truc qui est totalement
étranger au pouvoir politique est bien
jamais personne ne s'est donné la peine
de réfléchir à qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire si le monde devait se présenter
d'une façon très différente et donc ce
que j'ai dit à ce moment là c'est qu'on
avait cherché à faire repartir les
activités comme avant et que ça ne
marcherait pas pour une raison très
simple c'est que le placard ce vide
encore un peu plus par rapport à ce
qu'il était déjà vidé avant et en
particulier quelque chose qui va
empêcher le plan de relance de
fonctionner normalement c'est la décrue
de l'approvisionnement pétrolier il se
trouve que l'approvisionnement pétrolier
et depuis maintenant cinquante ans le
premier facteur limitant de l'économie
mondiale parce que ils conditionnent
l'abondance de transport et les
transports c'est le premier facteur
limitant de la communication générale
dans la machine des flux globaux de
l'économie vous n'avez pas une
entreprise qui est en train de m'écouter
vous n'avez pas un objet qu'il soit
nécessaire à son fonctionnement qui ne
viennent de chine ne serait ce que les
vêtements que vous portez pour aller au
travail ou des composants des vêtements
que vous portez pour aller au travail
donc sans porte conteneurs fonctionnant
au pétrole qui sillonnent la planète
eh bien il n'y a pas une entreprise
aujourd'hui qui fonctionne de la même
manière
donc si vous avez moins de
porte-conteneurs vous avez moins de
produits qui viennent de chine à court
terme et dont
vous avez des codes amitié ralenti parce
que vous avez une partie de ce qui nous
est nécessaire qu'il est plus disponible
on l'a bien vu avec les principes actifs
là lors de l'épidémie
je peux vous dire qu'il ya un labo
pharma de renom ils sont pas passés loin
de la catastrophe parce qu'une partie
des principes actifs qui est fabriqué en
chine c'est pas dans la province du
bailleur mais c'était pas loin
donc aujourd'hui on a un déchet de
mondialisé où le pétrole encore une fois
est le premier facteur limitant or le
pétrole est probablement passé par son
maximum historique fin 2018 est en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'avec la
crise il ya un phénomène qui s'est
enclenchée mais qui c'est elle qui était
si tu es déjà enclenché à petite vitesse
avant qu'ils aient compris pétrole
s'effondre du coup les investissements
dans l'amont pétrolier s'effondre et du
coup la production va diminuer dans pas
longtemps ça a déjà commencé en fait
rapidement aux états unis et à partir du
moment où la production diminue la
consommation on ne peut pas être plus
importante que la production qui a
diminué
donc ça veut dire que l'économie ne peut
pas revenir dans son état antérieur donc
quand monsieur le maire dit sur bfm
les 450 milliards de dettes qu'on vienne
créer on va les rembourser avec la
croissance
moi j'ai envie de lui demander puisque
je suis sûr de gagner mon pari j'ai
envie de parier un milliard d'euros
contre lui ça ne sera pas pareil france
que silva ses héritiers nous raconte des
salades et en plus le pire c'est qu'il
le sait donc le vote question étant de
savoir pourquoi mais donc l'économie ne
repartira pas comme avant c'est juste
pas possible
donc si on essaye de la faire repartir
comme avant en gros on va aider un
éclopé à se relever mais il va se casser
la gueule par longtemps derrière c'est
juste ça qu'on est en train de préparer
la prochaine crise donc c'est donc
reprendre mon parallèle c'est peut-être
douloureux mais autant vider l'abcès
tout de suite et repartir tout de suite
d'une manière assez aussi différentes
que possible alors là il ya plein de
frein au tout à l'heure on va poser la
question qu'est ce que je ferais si
j'étais président de l'ue en fait
j'étais président de l'uae à des crimes
que je ferai c'est de militer pour que
l'union européenne revienne à ses
origines qui est de vivre en paix ses
origines ne sont pas de faire un marché
jamais l'union européenne n'a eu pour
mandat de faire un marché avant toute
chose et maintenant on confond la fin et
les moyens c'est à dire au motif que le
marché et permet aux gens de se
connaître et de faire des
faire ensemble ce qu'on voyait comme un
moyen de maintenir la paix on a confondu
la fin et les moyens et maintenant c'est
plus la paix l'objectif ultime de
l'union c'est un marché mais le problème
c'est que trop de marche et il va tuer
la peine trop de marché va tuer la paix
merci donc c'était le mot de la fin de
cette question cette réponse à la
question suivante est ce que les efforts
sur nos territoires ne seront pas
annihilé par le laisser-aller d'autres
pays comme les usa alors la réponse est
doublement non elle est non parce que il
ya un pari pascalien est allé non pour
des raisons physiques
si les autres pays ne font pas d'efforts
ça veut dire qu'ils vont tirer le plus
vite possible sur le réservoir bibine
qui s'appelle le pétrole
donc ça veut dire qu'il en restera moins
pour nous donc ça veut dire qu'on va se
décarbonés devenir forcé au lieu de se
dé carbonée de manière active donc le
grand paradoxe dans le monde finit dans
lequel nous sommes
c'est que moins les autres sont des
forts et plus nous parce qu'en france on
importe la totalité de nos combustibles
fossiles on sera forcé d'en faire
rapidement et en particulier si les pays
qui produisent des combustibles fossiles
décidé ne pas faire d'effort c'est à
dire qu'ils le gardent pour eux en
quantité croissante
la deuxième raison pour laquelle ça vaut
le coup de faire des efforts c'est que
le mode de raisonnement dans lequel on
se dit je ne fais pas d'effort parce que
les autres n'en font pas est un système
dans lequel à l'arrière on est sûr de
perdre ce que personne n'en fait donc
peut-être que si on fait des efforts on
gagnera pas par contre on est sûr que si
on en fait pas on perd donc il ya un
pari pascalien derrière qui est évident
qu'il faut faire des efforts
par ailleurs il ya un deuxième une
troisième raison qui est essentiel c'est
que le fatalisme n'engendre pas l'espoir
alors que l'action oui
et ça les chefs d'entreprise sont bien
placés pour savoir donc peut-être qu'une
partie des combats ce qu'on dit qu'on va
perdre une avance mais en attendant le
temps qu'on le mène on se portera quand
même toujours mieux que si on se laisse
abattre
c'est la fameuse histoire du colibri
c'est la fameuse histoire du sens de
l'effort et du sens de l'action et du
fait que agir c'est déjà une forme
d'optimisme et qu'en plus je suis loin
de penser que tout est perdu dans le
temps presse c'est évident mais tout
n'est pas encore perdu en évidence aussi
le dernier point c'est que il faut bien
voir qu'aujourd'hui en fait on est en
train de se réveiller d'une période
d'une parenthèse un peu inhabituel dans
l'histoire des hommes qui était une
parenthèse dans laquelle on n'a pas eu
de contrainte la guerre on n'a pas eu à
rien mais c'est une parenthèse dans
l'histoire des hommes
pas de pandémie quand typiquement c'est
une parenthèse dans l'histoire des
hommes
sadate des vaccins et les antibiotiques
c'est très récent donc je dis pas que
c'est une bonne chose qu'on retrouve les
pende et je te dis juste que ça nous a
rendu un peu indolent à peu paresseux un
peu etc voilà il faut retrouver l'envié
de se battre alors pas nécessairement
les uns que les autres
j'ai pas du tout aimé le goût de guerre
de macron combat je veux bien
bergé - mais par contre le fait qu'il va
falloir oser affronter l'adversité
oui c'est évident ça va demander de
l'action collective et ça va demander de
la solidarité
merci question d'un mickaël croyez vous
qu'il soit possible un jour de capter ou
d'aspirer le co2 et si oui cela
pourrait-il résoudre le problème du
réchauffement climatique
il ya une très très belle pompe à
carbone sur terre qui s'appelle la
végétation est en fait c'est de très
loin la plus efficace c'est la seule qui
marche très bien à grande échelle
aujourd'hui pour vous donner des ordres
de grandeur la végétation absorbe chaque
année 120 milliards de tonnes de carbone
donc en gros 490% 450 milliards de
tonnes de co2 en provenance de
l'atmosphère
sauf que l on aurait aimé instantanément
la moitié c'est la respiration des
plantes passe
trouve que les plantes respire comme
nous et l'autre moitié est restituée
sous forme de respiration des animaux
alors quels sont les animaux qui
respirent tous les to les herbivores qui
mangent des feuilles il respire et il
recrache le carbone qui est contenu dans
les feuilles les animaux comme nous
qu'ils mangent à la fois des végétaux et
des animaux quand on mange des animaux
en mangent de carbone qui était dans les
plantes et qui est passé dans les
animaux ça qu'on mange et puis il ya
également des animaux qui émettent
beaucoup beaucoup tout petits qui
s'appelle les microbes qui sont les
animaux qui décomposent en matières
végétales morte donc par exemple à
litière en forêt les feuilles mortes etc
quand vous voyez le bois se décomposer
en fait c'est des micro organismes
puissent entreprendre manger le bois en
question ou les failles en question est
saisie pour avis par respire est donc en
voie d oxyde de carbone dans
l'atmosphère
les émissions d'origine humaine
aujourd'hui ses 60 milliards de tonnes
alors sur le strict co2 ces points que
ça c'est 45 milliards de tonnes de co2
alors 45 milliards de tonnes par rapport
à 450 on peut penser que c'est pas
beaucoup mais en fait c'est suffisant
pour déséquilibrer l'équipe pour
déséquilibrer système
c'est bien pour ça qu'il ya alors ce
qu'on se dit aussi c'est qu'il suffirait
que les l'absorption de la végétation
augmente de 10%
et puis on a réglé le problème sauf que
pour ça il faudrait que la couverture de
la végétation augmente alors
qu'aujourd'hui elles diminuent à cause
de la déforestation et il faudrait qu'on
arrive à capturer de plus en plus de
carbone dans les sols agricoles alors
qu'aujourd'hui on le des stocks au
travers des pratiques de labourage et
c'est donc les le plus gros potentiel
pour récupérer du carbone de
l'atmosphère c'est de laisser faire la
végétation de deux manières en essayant
d'accroître la surface forestière et
alors je vais revenir après ce qu'est ce
que ça signifie un ca et en remettant du
carbone dans les sols agricoles alors su
remettre du carbone dans les sols
agricoles ça veut dire en gros
- labouré voire plus la bourrée du tout
et ça veut dire beaucoup plus de travail
fin de la terre donc remettre de la main
d'oeuvre
c'est ça que ça veut dire en clair donc
ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui vont
accepter de retourner dans l'agriculture
et évidemment ça va faire monter le prix
de la production agricole de façon ça va
monter de toute façon il faut voir qu'il
ya deux siècles
l'alimentation c'était deux tiers du
budget des ménages aujourd'hui
l'alimentation stricto sensu 7 2%
le ticket de caisse en sortie de
magasins c6 mais là dedans l'essentiel
de ce que vous payez c'est pas de la
nourriture c'est le salaire du
magasinier le salaire de la caissière
le coût de construction du magasin le
coût des camions qui ont acheminé de la
nourriture le coût de fabrication des
emballages en carton et en plastique le
coût de la campagne de pub de carrefour
et des dividendes des actionnaires de
carrefour donc plus payer
essentiellement tout sur de la
nourriture quand vous payez votre ticket
de caisse la nourriture stricto sensu
encore une fois c'est 2% il ya deux
siècles c'était 65%
ça nous donne une petite idée de la
baisse du prix de la nourriture qui a eu
grâce à l'énergie qui a permis de
remplacer travail des hommes par des
machines qui valent rien il est évident
qu'ils n'avaient culture plus résiliente
offert à son coût de production
augmenter ça renvoie à ce que j'essaie
tout à l'heure sur le coup du golfe qui
doit être multipliée par six si on veut
diviser le cheptel bovin par deux et les
éleveurs donc qui a développé toutes les
techniques dans laquelle culture qui est
pas mal de séquestrer le carbone on est
sain et pour augmenter la couverture
forestière il ya deux choses qu'il faut
faire c'est diminuer la taille de la
population et diminuer la part carnet
dans l'alimentation
parce que la couverture forestière
diminue pour faire place à la culture
essentiellement ça la raison de la
diminution de la couverture forestière
et les cultures augmente parce que la
population augmente et parce que la part
carnet dans l'alimentation augmentent
donc les deux bonnes mesures anti
déforestation et donc procès aux deux
capturés par les forêts c'est s'occuper
du planning familial et manger moins de
viande ça sera beaucoup plus efficace
que toutes les routes de perdre un
parent technologiques auxquels on peut
penser pour essayer de faire des machins
avec des petites ailettes qui tourne
dans l'atmosphère pour qu'on paie le co2
comme les shadoks et le match et pro ok
merci donc limitation de la population
logis wii aura au moins une limitation
de sa route il ya des mesures qui ont
fait la preuve de leur efficacité qui
sont au nombre de trois ces l'éducation
des femmes l'accès à des moyens de
contraception et les mesures de
solidarité aux questions de laurent la
période de coheed des deux derniers mois
a permis au brésil de supprimer encore
impunément 1200 kilomètres carrés de
forêt amazon amazonienne
à quand le devoir d'ingérence climatique
s'ils ont demandé aux français de ne pas
couper leurs forêts à quelles conditions
est ce que les français n'accepteraient
à mon avis si on les paye pour ça donc
je pense que l'autre option et ont
effectivement qu'on nous envoie les
chars et les avions en nous disant c'est
pas bien ce que vous faites et on va
vous taper sur la tête
eh bien je pense qu'en ce qui concerne
le brésil c'est exactement les deux
mêmes options qui se présentent donc ou
bien on pense qu'on peut les anéantir en
envoyant les chars et les avions ce qui
est une option qui ne paraît discutable
bien faut qu'on les paye ne vois pas
d'autre système qui fonctionnera et donc
les pays de l'extérieur dans le pays où
elle est payée de l'extérieur on leur
dit vous détenez vous avez la chance les
bédouins ont eu la chance de détenir un
truc qui intéressait tout le monde ils
sont fortement enrichi donc les
présidents ont la chance de détenir un
actif tant mieux pour eux
si on veut être sérieux sur la question
n'est pas là moi j'y suis prêt je suis
personnellement beaucoup plus prêt à
payer les brésiliens pour que il jardine
la forêt amazonienne ou qui la préserve
plutôt que de payer les fabricants de
panneaux solaires chinois pour remplacer
le nucléaire qui me va bien
donc voilà je pense qu'en ce moment en
france où il est en train de déconner à
plein tube sur la manière dont on
emploie notre argent alors qu'on
pourrait faire avec qui tu as donné
l'argent à l'extérieur des trucs
considérablement plus intelligent qu'est
ce qu'on fait en soi pourquoi le sujet
de l'explosion démographique est un peu
tabou lorsqu'on parle de dérèglements
climatiques essentielles du problème
deviendra t'il pas de l'ain quelles
solutions dans ce domaine c'est très
difficile c'est un sujet difficile parce
que c'est un sujet culturel c'est un
sujet tripale c'est un sujet qui renvoie
à notre cerveau primitif à notre cerveau
primitif il nous dira produits toi
autant que tu peux ce qui a donné
mythique et tous ses dérivés
parce que tu sais pas combien de
représentants de l'espèce survivront
donc c'est un sujet qui est très très
difficile à aborder
si un sujet où le nauséabond n'est
jamais très loin
l'eugénisme et génocide etc donc c'est
un sujet difficile alors il ya des voies
et moyens qu'ils ont quand je disais
tout à l'heure sont moins difficiles que
d'autres et en particulier tout ce qui
permet aux gens de choisir délibérément
de ne pas faire d'enfant c'est
évidemment des mesures qui sont à
privilégier de très loin alors là dedans
vous en avez un certain nombre je le
répète alors qu'angers d'éducation des
femmes c'est un peu plus précis que ça
c'est la prise de pouvoir des femmes
pour être plus précis l'éducation étant
une des manières d'y arriver
la deuxième chose qui fonctionne c'est
l'accès à des moyens de contraception
quand les couples le souhaitent quand
les femmes de souhaite que les hommes le
souhaite parce qu'il ya aussi les mains
une contraception masculin et la
troisième mesure c'est les mesures de
solidarité une des raisons pour
lesquelles on fait plein d'enfants dans
certains pays c'est parce que comme il
n'ya pas de régime de retraite
vous vous dites et bien j'en fais plein
parce que comme ça je suis à peu près
sûr que l'un de mes enfants prendra soin
de moi quand je serai vieux donc ça
c'est des choses qui sont faciles à
faire
facile à faire au sens 2 mais ça n'est
pas des chocs culturels la contraception
un peu mais le reste pas trop on y
arrive
donc ça c'est déjà des choses faciles à
faire et puis après il faut avoir un
débat adultes est-ce qu'en france par
exemple cela fait sens d'avoir encore
une fiscalité data liste ça se discute
pas complètement sûr en tout cas je suis
sûr qu'il faut en discuter
c'est absolument certain voilà donc
c'est un débat qui est difficile parce
que pour des raisons encore une fois
parce que viau logiquement on est câblé
comme tous les animaux pour se
reproduire autant qu'on peut parce que
tant qu'on avait des prédateurs c'était
une question de survie de l'espèce et
depuis qu'on a plus de prédateurs c'est
à dire que la prophylaxie beaucoup les
médicaments un peu la technologie un peu
nous ont permis de nous échapper
d'échappée totalement à nos prédateurs
en aide aux populations qui prolifèrent
et notre cortex n'a pas pris le relais
pour nous dire que calme-toi un peu là
on arrête pour finir là-dessus il faut
bien voir qu'un des trucs que notre
cortex doit nous dire c'est que à partir
du moment
où on devient une population non régulés
sur un espace fini on est en train de
signer pour des régulations involontaire
et même si ça n'est pas directement liée
au changement climatique il ya très
longtemps que je dis que dans les
régulations involontaire qui s'applique
à grande échelle pour la population via
lac 2 1 c'est la famine et la maladie
donc effectivement comme il a été dit
tout à l'heure
le coc vide n'est qu'une petite
répétition un petit avant goût de ce qui
nous attend au plus tard dans un monde
dans lequel on ne s'occupe pas d'appuyer
de nous mêmes sur la [ __ ] de frein
alors j'ai une question qui monte qui
monte qui monte de stéphanie peuple ans
est alors de la relocalisation de
l'économie
il ya le travail manuel l'apprentissage
le biais et ainsi redonner du sens au
social et tendre vers la transition
environnementale durable responsable ce
qui nous a permis de nous affranchir du
travail manuel
depuis deux siècles c'est les machines
alors que les machines font le travail
manuel place c'est bien pour ça que vous
voyez un tracteur développe la même
puissance que des centaines de paires de
jambes donc vous donner un tracteur un
agriculteur et vous remplacer des
dizaines d'animaux de traits plus des
dizaines d'ouvriers qui ont plus besoin
d'être dans les champs avant quand vous
aviez besoin de gens avec des faux pour
faucher blé
ce n'était pas exactement les mêmes
effectifs que vous aviez dans
l'agriculture donc le monde dans lequel
l'énergie diminuent est un monde de
toute façon dans lequel on va devoir
retrouver l'envié du travail manuel
après la bonne question c'est est ce
qu'on est passé maintenant qu'on est
passé par la case l'activité
technologique est ce que ça va être des
activités pur ou est-ce qu'il ya plein
de gens qui auront deux activités je
suis un paysan le matin et puis pourquoi
enseignants l'après midi ou donc ça
c'est une question intéressante pour moi
est ce que la reconfiguration du travail
va se faire avec une forme de mixité
dans les activités parce que
l'agriculteur reliés au monde extérieur
mais aussi éduquer que n'importe qui
peut-être qu'il n'aura pas envie de
ramasser des patates toute la journée
qu'il aura envie et une partie du temps
de faire autre chose et inversement
l'urbain peut très bien passer la moitié
de son temps à cultiver un jardin pour
faire pousser certains voient là
j'ai pas les idées totalement claires
sur la façon dont le travail va
peut-être se reconfigurer dans cette
affaire là ce qui est sûr c'est que la
part du travail manuel doit augmenter et
que contrairement à une idée qui a
souvent été évoquée le monde dans lequel
on se dématérialise pour de vrai c'est à
dire où la part des machines diminue
mais pas du tout un monde de bureau dans
lequel on tape le carton toute la
journée
c'est un monde dans lequel on va re
transpirer un peu plus dans ce monde là
c'est évident que l'apprentissage a
toute sa place parce que c'est une façon
traditionnelle d'apprendre les métiers
manuels
c'est compliqué d'attendre d'apprendre
un métier manuel avec doigté soit dit en
passant il ya des métiers pas manuel
qu'on ferait bien aussi d'apprendre avec
un peu moins de théorie un peu plus de
pratique mais bon c'est pas beau le
débat donc il ya un donc je pense que
c'est un monde vers lequel et c'est
parfaitement compatible avec des
sociétés ont évolué regardez par exemple
la part de l'apprentissage en suisse qui
est extrêmement développé j'ai pas
l'impression que les suisses soit des
gens particulièrement idiot et
particulièrement incapable donc c'est un
système qui marche très bien à tous les
niveaux de l'éducation et diplômes et et
c'est une très bonne nouvelle pour moi
que ça commence à se développer partout
et tout le temps la relique alisation
oui parce que la mondialisation est
arrivé grâce au pétrole abondant c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure
donc un monde dans lequel d'énergie est
moins abondante est un monde dans lequel
l'activité va être plus relocalisez'
alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
les unités de fabrication vont redevenir
plus polyvalente
on pourra pas segmenter les phases de
fabrication de façon aussi importante
qu'on le fait aujourd'hui avec les
cabines qui sont peintes ici assemblée
la forge est encore ailleurs etc
les activités industrielles d'il ya un
siècle étaient des activités beaucoup
plus intégrée qu'elles ne le sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus intégré donc
ça veut dire ça qu'on va devoir
retrouver une polyvalence ça veut dire
qu'on va avoir des activités qui seront
plus résiliente est moins performante
quand elles sont dans leur zone de
confort
c'est en particulier que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que le prix des produits va
remonter puisqu'on pourra plus optimisé
en fonction de l'optimum de chaque pays
avec le transport qui vaut rien voilà
tout ce que ça veut dire
et ça veut dire qu'on va avoir des
produits qui se renouvelle au moins
souvent qui coûteront plus cher et on
réparera plus tout cela doit rappeler
des souvenirs de grands parents un
certain nombre d'entre vous parce que
c'est à peu près comme ça que fonctionne
l économie à un moment où les énergies
étaient beaucoup plus contrainte alors
ce qu'on n'aura pas supprimée dans
l'intervalle c'est un capital de
connaissances accumulées qui pourra
probablement permettre de fonctionner
d'une façon différente de ce que c'était
il ya un siècle
mais par contre on va retrouver des
grands déterminant qui font quand même
penser à partie et pour finir sur la
mondialisation grâce à l'énergie
abondante un truc très physique qu'il
faut avoir en tête
à l'époque où l'énergie étaient rares et
donc le transport valait très cher ce
qui est est mondialisée c'était des
choses qui valait un prix astronomique
paru 10,3 donc on mondialisée les
pierres précieuses lors des épices la
soie est un peu le sel voilà puis ça
s'arrêtait là aujourd'hui on mondialise
des trucs qui va le 50 euros la tonne ça
n'a aucun sens ça n'a aucun sens et donc
plus l'énergie deviendra contraintes et
plus resteront mondialisée les trucs qui
valent très très cher par unité de
points donc on peut imaginer que les
sacs hermès reste mondialisée plus
longtemps que la fabrication de voitures
ou la fabrication de pots pour plantes
de jardin la question suivante pourquoi
le nucléaire vous va bien
réponse très courte parce que c'est un
élément qui abaisse le risque global
dans le paysage que je viens de décrire
vous avez compris que dans le paysage
que je viens de décrire plus on crache
de co2 plus on risque de transformer la
terre en enfer et plus on compte sur les
combustibles fossiles épuisable plus
vite on va à la contraction économique
subie avec tous les problèmes sociaux
que ça va poser dans cette affaire le
nucléaire est un amortisseur de la
décroissance pour moi j'ai jamais cru au
nucléaire comme une manière d'avoir la
croissance perpétuelle c'est pas ça qui
m'intéresse dans le nucléaire je ne
crois pas à la croissance perpétuelle
même avec le nucléaire par contre c'est
un amortisseur de la décroissance donc
ça permettra de décroître moins vite que
si on l'a pas
alors à me dire mais les énergies
renouvelables aussi non malheureusement
il faut 10 à 100 fois plus de métal par
kilowattheure produit quand on fait du
solaire ou de l'éolien quand on fait du
nucléaire et donc le fait que
transitoirement les énergies
renouvelables peuvent elles peuvent
valoir moins cher que le nucléaire c'est
un artefact qui ne reflète pas les
avantages physiques intrinsèque du
nucléaire et du solaire et de l'éolien
c'est juste un artefact transitoire on
peut pas durer c'est notamment liée au
fait que les mâts d'éoliennes et les
pales d'éoliennes et les panneaux
solaires sont fabriqués aujourd'hui et
que l'énergie fossile et de manière
mondialisée tout est fait en chine
le jour où on aura que des éoliennes et
des panneaux solaires pour faire en
france les éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires avec le cuivre français issus
des mines françaises que nous n'avons
pas le faire français issus des mines
françaises que nous n'avons pas non plus
etc
on en reparlera des prix c'est évident
que ça sera pas du tout le prix actuel
donc le nucléaire il vaut moins cher
pour une raison très simple
enfin oui devant de moins de moyens
c'est que l'énergie nucléaire est un
million de fois plus puissante que
l'énergie chimique
vous avez autant d'énergie dans la
fiction d'un gramme d'uranium que dans
la combustion d'une tonne de pétrole à
cause de cette caractéristique physique
intrinsèque vous avez besoin de
dispositifs qui sont intrinsèquement
petit pour avoir de grandes quantités
d'énergie dont vous même si c'est
beaucoup de béton dans une centrale
ce que c'est dangereux à l'intérieur
c'est quand même moins de béton par
kilowattheure produit qu'avec des
éoliennes
même si vous avez besoin d'une cuve en
acier très épaisse et qu'on surveille
comme le lait sur le feu
eh bien vous avez besoin de moins
d'acier par kilowattheure produit dans
le nucléaire que avec des éoliennes et
des panneaux solaires et par ailleurs
c'est pilotable pour quand vous tournez
bouton z d'électricité alors que
l'éolien et le solaire là et bien oui
binaire aurait déjà dû s'arrêter puisque
les deux seules équipes assurent
lorillon gelé dans les yeux alors
qu'avant il était haut sur l'horizon et
donc le réseau se serait arrêté de
fonctionner là maintenant si on comptait
uniquement sur le solaire on a organisé
notre société aujourd'hui non pas en
fonction d'eux quand il ya du vent ou du
soleil ça c'était la société des
énergies renouvelables donc
effectivement les bacs les cargaisons
arriver qu'il y avait du vent et quand
il y avait pas de vent les marins
amoureux du scorbut et les récoltes
séchait quand y avait du soleil et elle
se fait pas en plein hiver
aujourd'hui vous pouvez sécher des
récoltes en plein hiver si vous voulez
vous pouvez faire pousser des tomates en
plein hiver il est séché en plénière si
vous voulez parce qu'on a de l'énergie à
revendre entier pas de l'énergie
renouvelable
alors je dis pas que c'est une très
bonne idée d'avoir les tomates en hiver
en l'occurrence a pas debout ça n'a
aucun intérêt mais c'est juste pour dire
que c'est totalement affranchi des
contraintes horaires et on a construit
une société qui n'en dépend plus et le
train de 8 heures par à 8 heures et deux
restants de reproche à l'ex et celle ci
part à 8h05
le train de 8 heures par à 8 heures qui
est du vent ou pas de vent et votre
frigo fournit une bière fraîche au mois
d'août qu'il y ait du vent ou pas de
vent et du soleil ou pas de soleil et
vos entreprises ouvrent à 8h ou 9h du
matin qu'il y ait du vent ou pas de vent
avec les énergies renouvelables non
pilotable ce système ne fonctionne pas
donc vous êtes obligé de revenir un
système dans lequel votre bureau ouvre
s'il ya du vent
si on veut que le bureau ouvre à 9
heures quand ils arrivent il faut
compléter avec du stockage et c'est là
que ça devient un problème indémodable
parce que l'électricité ce stock très
mal c'est la raison pour laquelle la
voiture électrique n'a jamais pris le
pas sur la voiture à pétrole c'est parce
que c'est très très difficile de stocker
dans la voiture suffisamment
d'électricité pour lui permettre d'aller
loin
il a fallu des prouesses technologiques
récentes pour ça commence à devenir
possible
donc en ce qui concerne l'électricité
jamais les batteries nous permettront de
stocker suffisamment d'électricité sur
un réseau pour qu'il fonctionne
uniquement à les éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires n'est pas le temps de
développer
bien sûr quand on fait les calculs on se
rend compte que ça ne marchera jamais
donc les énergies renouvelables ne
permettront jamais de se défaire
totalement des énergies fossiles dans la
production électrique parce qu'il y aura
toujours besoin d'un dispositif
pilotable qu'ils soient là pour prendre
le relais quand ya pas de vent pas de
soleil donc en fait contrairement à
l'idée qu'on peut penser ça ne permet
pas de décarbonés totalement la
production électrique ça permet de
commencer à la décarbonée mais on n'ira
pas jusqu'au bout du chemin avec juste
de l'éolien et du solaire donc la raison
pour laquelle j'aime le nucléaire c'est
parce qu'il permet d'aller plus vite à
moyen de l'est pour virer les centrales
à charbon c'est ça qui m'intéresse et
que comme il permet de préserver une
plus grande quantité d'énergie dans un
monde où l'énergie va se contracter de
toute façon il permet d'amortir la chute
de l'économie et donc d'amortir la
désagrégation des sociétés
et plus on remplace des centrales à
charbon par nucléaire et plus on baisse
le risque global et plus je suis un
homme heureux
les inconvénients intrinsèque du
nucléaire quand vous les regardez ils
sont en tout point inférieur aux
inconvénients intrinsèque des
alternatives en tout point alors je vous
les énumérer si vous voulez les déchets
c'est tout petit comme le nucléaire
c'est très concentré la totalité des
déchets que nous avons déjà produit avec
le parc nucléaire français tient dans
une piscine à la règle une piscine à la
règle tout petit s'il ya des gens qui
nous écoutent en ce moment qu'ils ont
des entreprises qui font des déchets
dangereux
ils savent très bien que la totalité des
déchets dangereux en france ça tient pas
dans une piscine à vagues beaucoup plus
que ça mon bazar de chaque année dans la
nature des dizaines de milliers de
tonnes de phytosanitaires dont certains
sont unitairement presque aussi
dangereux que les déchets nucléaires
les déchets nucléaires n'ont jamais tué
personne
alors que les escaliers ici les voitures
si le tabac si donc le tabac reste en
vente libre dans ce pays je pas sûr
qu'il faille s'affoler sur les déchets
nucléaires
quand vous regardez le risque d'accident
j'ai beaucoup étudié les conséquences de
tchernobyl et fukushima fukushima n'a
pas fait un mort à cause du surplus de
radiation c'est pas moi qu'ils disent et
les nations unies il ya un rapport qui
est publié donc là aussi il ya plein de
littérature qui a été publié par
l'organisme compétent des nations unies
qui fonctionne comme le giec mais pour
le nucléaire qui a dit très exactement
ce que j'ai à vous dire que fukushima il
n'a pas fait un mort à cause du surplus
de radiations alors que popal usine
chimique a fait 5000 mort instantanée ou
un groupe ça va péter et personne ne dit
qu'il faut sortir de la chimie en face
il ya quelques personnes n'est pas avec
la même vigueur pour le nucléaire alors
que je vous assurer que le chili c'est
beaucoup plus dangereux que le nucléaire
le plus gros accident de centrales
électriques dans le monde ayant fait le
plus de morts et de très loin
c'est les ruptures de barrages beaucoup
plus que les centrales nucléaires il ya
la rupture du barrage de wagons garonne
en italie dans les années 50 qui a fait
2500 morts
en fait c'est pas une rupture de barrage
c'était un glissement de terrain dans le
lac de barrage 2500 morts beaucoup plus
que les mort instantanée à tchernobyl
pour construire le barrage des trois
gorges on a évacué un million de
personnes
a tchernobyl on s'est contenté d'en
évacuer 200 milles donc vous pouvez
prendre tout ce que vous voulez sur tous
les plans vous vous rendez compte qu'en
fait le nucléaire ne mérite pas
l'anathème qui est le sien en france et
qui a été développé pour des raisons qui
n'ont rien à
avec ses inconvénients intrinsèque moi
je mets ça dans la grande barque de lait
français est bien critiquer ce que fait
l'état parce qu'on adore critiquer le
pouvoir central et comme le nucléaire
est une énergie géré par le pouvoir
central
on y trouve des tas l'inconvénient parce
que quand même ce que fait le pouvoir
central qu'il s'agisse des flics ou du
nucléaire c'est pas terrible
c'est pour moi c'est beaucoup plus lié à
ça que liés à l'examen patients des
inconvénients un principe du nucléaire
qui ne mérite absolument pas qu'on
arrange pas du côté des problèmes mais
bien du côté des solutions mais
j'insiste c'est pas une solution qui va
nous empêcher l'essentiel des
environnements que j'ai évoqués c'est
mais c'est un sacré pansement sur la
plaie en parlons d'éducation des femmes
il paraîtrait que nous sommes plus
sensibles aux enjeux environnementaux
voire les nations dirigé par les femmes
vous voyez vous un levier pour les
inciter à prendre la parole le lieu sur
ce sujet où on les attend peu
c'est une excellente question et j'ai
toujours pas la réponse
je sais pas si l'endroit où les femmes
doivent prendre le pouvoir c'est à la
tête de la commission européenne ou si
c'est dans
partout et tout le temps j'ai envie de
dire c'est à dire dans toutes les
maisons dans toutes les entreprises mais
mais mais pas un pouvoir brutal un
pouvoir au sens d'une présence je ne
suis pas complètement sûr que madame von
der leyen affiche aujourd'hui une
préoccupation environnementale qu'on est
très supérieure à celle des dirigeants
qui l'ont précédé croiser un peu
elisabeth board aujourd'hui me semble
pas avoir une préoccupation
environnementale extrêmement développée
elle dit oui à ce que lui demande de
faire macron puis ça s'est vite à peu
près à ça donc je ne suis pas
complètement sûr que arrivée au pouvoir
aujourd'hui soit vraiment ce qui compte
ce que je constate à mon petit niveau
alors je vais être très prudent parce
que je voudrais pas être qualifié de
sexisme en primaire où es tu sais c'est
que quand les femmes sont présentes dans
le dialogue sur l'action de terrain j'ai
envie de dire au jour le jour
il ya un mieux sur ce plan là parce que
il ya une façon plus apaisée j'ai envie
de dire d'aborder les problèmes aux
postes de pouvoir
je suis je reste perplexe ouais je veux
dire autrement je pense que tant
qu'elles n'ont pas pris le pouvoir qui
leur revient c'est à dire le fait
exister au bon niveau dans la société
civile
je suis pas sûr que le fait de mettre
une pauvre une femme à la tête d'un
conseil d'administration où une femme à
la tête d'un état ça change grand chose
voilà ce que je vais dire autrement mais
je pense que pense pas que la part des
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration me paraît être un peu
sujets moins importants que la part des
femmes dans l'encadrement par exemple
dans une entreprise
sachant qu'il ya plein d'entreprises
dans lequel c'est difficile parce qu'on
fait avec le vivier avec lequel on a six
aujourd'hui dans la construction
automobile ou dans le bâtiment vous
souhaitez mettre vous souhaitez vous le
souhaitez vraiment un papa juste pas
rater dimanche avoir une forme de parité
dans l'encadrement là c'est dur parce
que vous devez fonctionner avec le
vivier de départ qui est difficile voilà
donc peut-être que le début
le tout début c'est de dire aux femmes
ne pas avoir peur d'aller se mettre dans
des filières qui les prédisposent à
exercer des responsabilités dans les
champs technique à supposer qu'elle en
ait envie donc jeu mais c'est une
question à laquelle je tire pas la
réponse
quand je reçois des habits féminins les
ils me disent mais si mais si c'est la
société qui les brime je sais toujours
pas d'avis sur la question brûle mal à
savoir alors on va prendre une dernière
question est-ce que voter écolo vous par
une bonne manière de faire bouger la
gestion politique de la crise
environnementale ou faut-il privilégier
un changement de système politique plus
profond alors la réponse est non
aujourd'hui voter écolo ça ne modifie
que très marginalement la manière dont
le système est géré parce que les
représentants du mouvement politique
écologiste
pour beaucoup les mêmes démons que ceux
des autres partis politiques
c'est très rare que ces gens là n'est
pas avant tout des enjeux de pouvoir en
tête
ils ont présenté d'une autre manière là
mêmes incohérences que les autres partis
politiques par exemple vous n'entendez
pas les mouvements écologistes vous dire
ce que je viens de vous dire moi de
manière très brutale et je ne vous dis
pas comme une bonne nouvelle
je vous le dis comme une mauvaise
nouvelle que gérer correctement
l'environnement sesmat origines et donc
on oublie de pouvoir d'achat et sa
hausse pour les mêmes pour les classes
modestes d'accor s'est passé
malheureusement vous les entendez pas
dire ça donc ils sont dans la même
contradiction tous les autres qui l efo
plus partout donc puisse d'environnement
et plus de pouvoir d'achat pour les
modestes
malheureusement non c'est donc on peut
commencer par tong riches
c'est une très bonne idée mais quand
vous faites les règles de droit vous
rendez compte le même ton gerrish c'est
pas suffisant pour éviter que les boles
voient leur pouvoir d'achat baisser dans
un monde qui va diviser ses émissions
par un facteur 6 marchera pas donc il
faut s'y prendre autrement
la bonne question c'est quoi le projet
qui conserve de l'espoir chez les
modestes alors même qu'ils vont perdre
du pouvoir d'achat
c'est ça mon cahier des charges c'est
pas je vais leur donner plus et ça
marchera pas donc les écolos ils sont
pétris de leurs propres contradictions
aussi en france ils sont tous anti
nucléaires alors que je viens de vous
expliquer que pour moi le nucléaire
était faisait partie des solutions
il ya une longue interview sur mon site
perso que j'ai donné à marianne ya
quelques mois qui détaille beaucoup de
ce que je viens de raconter sur duclair
donc donc je ne pense pas que voter
écolo ça fasse grand chose alors sais je
suis un peu je suis beaucoup plus
nuancée quand il s'agit des exécutifs
locaux
parce que dans les exécutifs locaux en
général les écolos là pour le coup se
battent pour des trucs qui sont beaucoup
plus intéressants parce que ils vont pas
se battre contre le nucléaire en france
c'est pas leur combat ils vont se battre
pour les pistes cyclables et
l'alimentation bio dans les cantines et
ça c'est des trucs intéressants donc
voter écolo au niveau national bon ça
n'a pas d'intérêt
voter écolo au niveau européen c'est
quand même de la croissance verte qui
vont nous sortir et je prends pas trop
par contre voter écolo dans l'action
locale ça ça peut avoir du sens
encore une fois parce que souvent c'est
des gens qui
qui vont s'intéresser à des trucs locaux
et c'est écolo là sont généralement
beaucoup plus intéressant que les écolos
nationaux mais c'est vrai pour tous les
partis politiques façon un peu général
vous avez aussi des tas de gens qui sont
pas marqués écolo qui vont faire
exactement le même genre de truc
localement vous savez on défendre des
trucs intéressants alors même qu'ils
sont pas écolo du tout je crois que ce
qui est vraiment intéressant aussi pour
toucher du doigt le pour qui on vote et
quels changements plus profonds je crois
que c'est important de passer à l'action
soi même donc ça renvoie à une des
premières questions qui est qu'est-ce
que le cjd pourrait faire et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire quand on est chef
d'entreprise je pense que la meilleure
manière d'avoir un avis sur quel est le
vote ce qui est pertinent c'est de
commencer à faire des choses soi-même et
de toucher du doigt ce que ça signifie
et donc là c'est on apprend par
l'expérience et on comprend où est ce
que le bât blesse et où est-ce qu'on
peut commencer
si ça se trouve c'est beaucoup plus
important pour les entreprises de faire
des choses sur la formation de faire des
choses sur l'organisation concurrentiel
de faire des choses sur la structure du
capital ou que sais-je que de voter
écolo
si ça se trouve je ne sais pas voilà
donc il ya des je pense qu'il faut avoir
une approche résolument pragmatique dans
ce domaine là est ce que le grand soir
politique est un truc qui est
souhaitable alors la réponse est oui il
me faut être sûr que ce soit le bon donc
quand on tombe sur un despote qui
s'appelle de gaulle on a de la chance
sera tiré le bon numéro quand il
s'appelle hitler c'est moins drôle
donc le la question de deux on va dire
de renforcer le pouvoir et d'avoir
quelque chose qui permet de se mettre en
économie guerre comme les dictateurs il
faut vraiment être sûr je vous rappelle
que les états unis sont passés en
économie de guerre pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale sans quitter la
démocratie et que les anglais ont passé
la guerre sans quitter la démocratie
donc moi ce que j'espère c'est qu'on va
arriver à quelque chose qui sera un
consensus suffisamment fort dans la
population pour que l'on soit capable de
faire de grandes choses tout en
abdiquant pas totalement nos libertés
individuelles
si jean-marc on arrive au terme de ce
web il est tard le soleil ton que vous
allez bientôt être dans la nuit pierre
peut-être que peut-être des choses à
dire pour porter ensemble
non mais je remercie jean marc pour pour
son intervention et puis effectivement
je pense que la suite et est assez
logique
je pense qu'à des ponts plus que des
ponts à construire des autoroutes et
même si j'aime pas trop les autres avec
l'a1 la flamme
enfin construire des choses un peu plus
un peu plus soutenue avec the chief
project et ben je remercie notamment la
section pour avoir mené ça et donc je
pense que c'est un une chance qu'on se
rend compte mais j'aimerais te qu'on
trouve une vraie date parce que comme on
est nous des gens qui agissent
je pense que là il faut trouver un vrai
rendez vous avec une vraie date
et puis trouver des chemins nous ce qui
nous a été associé jdc mener des
expérimentations je pense que c'est ce
qui nous caractérise et donc à partir de
choses qui sont potentiellement faisable
maintenant concrètement par les
entreprises parce que c'est ça notre
champ d'action
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait prendre comme
mesures concrètes pour des entreprises
ou des écosystèmes qui pourrait même
fonctionner et expérimenté ça on fait
très souvent cjd ont fait voilà pour les
entreprises qui s'engagent et moi je
pense que ça peut commencer et qu'il
faut faire voilà tout simplement
moi je serais ravi et je suis d'autant
plus ravi que c'est plus facile on est
plus agile intellectuellement et plus
mobile quand on est jeune on est aussi
moins prisonnier de ses rentes et c'est
toujours très difficile de changer une
fois qu'on est prisonnier de ses rentes
c'est bien le problème et plus on est
proche du pouvoir est en général plus on
a mis de temps à monter et plus on est
vieux et puis on est prisonnier de ses
rentes
c'est une des raisons qui me font penser
que l'élite en place sera la dernière à
bouger parce que c'est celle qui a le
plus à perdre
intellectuellement économiquement et
c'est pour l'avoir bien fréquenté je
pense que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
et c'est pour moi plus intéressant de
discuter avec des gens qui sont plus
mobiles et
parce que l'outragé des ans a été un peu
moins important réalité biologique
on est d'autant moins accessible vous
prenez ou une personne qui a 55 ans j'ai
jamais entendu parler du changement
climatique une entreprise il est foutu
déterminé n'en ferait rien sauf à ce que
ça renvoie à une crise d'adolescence pas
évacué kiki qui couve depuis 20 ans donc
moi je suis absolument ravi qu'on ouvre
un chantier
l'expérimentation et ce sera bien bloqué
pour en discuter on comprend d'être
c'est parti mais le mot de la fin
oui donc un premier rendez-vous de prix
on n'oublie pas le nôtre non plus le 6
mai 2021
du coup au corps de l'événement qui
était censé avoir lieu aujourd'hui on
sera très heureux de vous accueillir à
bouaké c'est un projet que l'on mène en
fait avec avec voilà toutes les
associations locales de chefs
d'entreprise avec le soutien des
collectivités locales d' voilà de tous
les acteurs locaux et on a vraiment le
projet que ça soit une journée en fait
qui soit 1 point mais dans une action
continue qui aura commencé avant
l'événement et qui se poursuivra après
pour accompagner les entreprises dans la
transition de la meilleure façon
merci beaucoup pour tout ce que vous
avez partagé avec une ce soir la
situation et les grades mais j'aime
en fait votre entendre votre optimisme
j'aime entendre aussi je le fait que en
passant par l'action il ya encore de
l'espoir est encore des solutions et
comme dit pierre at-il dit qu'on est des
meilleurs sauts cjd en effet je pense
qu'on a des belles choses à faire
ensemble
un grand merci merci merci beaucoup à
tous je suis ravi d'avoir mais cette
occasion et puis donc à bientôt
[Musique]